- Welcome to the Huberman Lab Podcast,
where we discuss science
and science-based tools for everyday life.
[upbeat music]
I'm Andrew Huberman,
and I'm a Professor of
Neurobiology and Ophthalmology
at Stanford School of Medicine.
Today, we are going to discuss
the science and practice
of flexibility and stretching.
Flexibility and stretching
are topics that I believe
do not receive nearly as much
attention as they deserve.
For most people, the topics
of flexibility and stretching
bring to mind things like yoga,
injury prevention, or
maybe even contortionism.
But it turns out that
flexibility and stretching
are features that are built
into our basic body plan.
Young children, young animals, and adults,
and, indeed, older children and animals
all stretch and all have
some degree of flexibility.
It turns out that having flexibility,
and our ability to stretch,
and the interaction between
stretching and flexibility
are fundamental to how we move,
our ability to learn new movements,
indeed also to prevent
injury or repair injuries,
and to offsetting and
reducing inflammation
throughout the body.
In fact, today I'm going to share with you
a remarkable set of studies
that show that stretching
can actually adjust
things like tumor growth.
This is work that was done
by one of the major directors
of the National Institutes of Health.
So, today's discussion will start
with a description of the mechanisms,
literally the cells
and the connections
from your nervous system
that mediate flexibility and stretching.
And I promise that I'll make
that information accessible to you
whether or not you have a
biology background or not.
Then with that information in hand,
I'm going to present to you
what the scientific literature
says about the best times
and ways to stretch,
everything right down to the detail
of how long to hold a stretch,
whether or not to hold a stretch at all
because it turns out there are
multiple kinds of stretching.
So, you can imagine you have stretches
where you hold the stretch
for a very long time
and use as little momentum as possible,
and then there's also
what's called dynamic
and ballistic stretching
where you're literally swinging your limbs
trying to increase the range of motion.
I will explain the science and application
of flexibility and stretching
in the context of sports performance,
whether or not you are engaging
in cardiovascular exercise,
or resistance exercise, or both,
whether or not you're
a competitive athlete
or simply a recreational
exerciser, as I am,
whether or not you are
trying to increase your range
of motion and flexibility
for longevity purposes,
or whether or not you're trying to do it
in order to access different
parts of your nervous system
'cause we'll soon learn today
that your ability to improve flexibility
and, indeed, to engage in
specific stretching exercises
can actually be used
to powerfully modulate
your ability to tolerate pain,
both emotional and physical pain.
So, this thing that we call
flexibility and stretching
is actually a vast landscape.
We're going to simplify and
organize all that for you today
and by the end of today's episode,
you're going to have a number
of simple, easy-to-apply tools
that are grounded in the
best scientific research
that you can apply for
your specific goals.
Before we begin, I'd like to
emphasize that this podcast
is separate from my teaching
and research roles at Stanford.
It is, however, part
of my desire and effort
to bring zero-cost to consumer information
about science and science-related tools
to the general public.
In keeping with that theme,
I'd like to thank the
sponsors of today's podcast.
Our first sponsor is Thesis.
Thesis makes custom nootropics
that are designed to
get your brain and body
into the optimal state for the
cognitive and physical things
that you need to perform
at the highest level.
I have to confess, in fact
I've said it many times before,
I am not a fan of the word nootropics
because it means smart drugs.
And frankly, as a neuroscientist,
I'd be remiss If I didn't acknowledge
that there's really no
circuit in your brain
for being smart,
you have neural circuits in
your brain that are designed
to get you to focus very well,
or to task switch very well,
or to be creative.
Thesis understands this,
and as a consequence
they've designed nootropics
that are tailored to your specific needs
in the cognitive and physical realm.
What I mean by that is if
you go to the Thesis site,
you fill out a short quiz,
and they'll give you the opportunity
to try a small kit of different nootropics
with different ingredients.
You have the opportunity to
try several different blends
over the course of the month
and discover which nootropics works best
for your unique brain
chemistry and genetics.
I've been using Thesis
for about eight and a half months now,
and I can confidently
say that their nootropics
have been a game changer.
To get your own personalized
nootropic starter kit,
you can go online to
takethesis.com/huberman.
There you'll find that three-minute quiz
and Thesis will send you
four different formulas
to try in your first month.
That's takethesis.com/huberman,
and use the code HUBERMAN at checkout
to get 10% off your first box.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by InsideTracker.
InsideTracker is a
personalized nutrition platform
that analyzes data from your blood and DNA
to help you better understand your body
and help you reach your health goals.
I've long been a believer in
getting regular bloodwork done
for the simple reason
that many of the factors
that impact your immediate
and long-term health
can only be analyzed from
a quality blood test.
One issue with a lot of blood
tests and DNA tests out there
is that you get information
back about hormone levels,
metabolic factors, et cetera,
but you don't know what to
do with that information.
InsideTracker has a very easy
to use personalized platform
that lets you look at those numbers
and then you can
literally move your cursor
over those numbers and there
are little popup windows
that will tell you the
things that you can do
in terms of lifestyle,
so exercise, and nutrition,
supplementation, and so on
to bring those numbers into the ranges
that are optimal for you.
So, it really takes all the
guesswork out of what to do
with that bloodwork and DNA information.
If you'd like to try InsideTracker,
you can visit insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans,
just use the code HUBERMAN at checkout.
That's insidetracker.com/huberman
to get 20% off any of
InsideTracker's plans,
again, just use the code
HUBERMAN at checkout.
Today's episode is also
brought to us by Eight Sleep.
Eight Sleep makes smart mattress covers
that have cooling, heating,
and sleep tracking capacity.
And, indeed, you can dial in,
you can literally program
the temperature of your
sleeping environment
from the time you go to sleep
until the time you wake up in the morning.
This turns out to be immensely powerful
because as I've talked
about on the podcast before,
in order to fall asleep
and stay deeply asleep
throughout the night,
your body has to drop by
about one to three degrees,
and waking up in the morning
actually involves a warming
up of your body temperature.
For many people, they just
can't precisely control
their sleep environment well enough
in order for all that to go well.
I was one such person.
So, for a long time I'd
fall asleep pretty easily,
but then I'd wake up in
the middle of the night,
I tended to run warm,
but then sometimes I'd feel
really tired in the morning
as if I couldn't wake up.
I started sleeping on an
Eight Sleep mattress cover.
I programmed it so that the temperature
would be rather cool in the
early part of the evening
when I would get into bed
and then would drop into the
deeper phases of the night
when I was entering deep sleep
and then rapid eye movement sleep,
and then would warm towards morning,
it would help me wake up quickly.
And as a consequence,
I'm sleeping throughout the night now
and I'm waking up feeling
completely refreshed.
If you'd like to try an
Eight Sleep mattress cover,
you can go to eightsleep.com/huberman
to check out the Pod Pro Cover
and save $150 at checkout.
Eight Sleep currently
ships within the USA,
Canada, and the United Kingdom.
Again, that's eightsleep.com/huberman
to save $150 at checkout.
Let's talk about
flexibility and stretching.
Before we talk about the practices
of flexibility and stretching,
I'd like to just highlight
some of the features
that are already built
into your nervous system
and into your body that
allow you to be flexible.
Some of us feel tighter than others,
sometimes in specific
limbs or areas of our body,
some people feel really loose and limb,
some people even have what's
called a hyper-flexibility.
I, for instance, have a relative
that can take her fingers
and bend them back to the point
where they touch her wrist.
And it always makes me
cringe a little bit,
but she can do that without any pain,
she seems to have some
hyper-flexibility in her joints.
I do not have that feature.
Some of you may find that
you are more flexible
than others naturally,
and some of you might be thinking
you don't need to build
in additional flexibility.
Well, I think by the
end of today's episode,
you'll realize that almost
all of us can benefit
from having some sort of
understanding about flexibility
and having some stretching protocol
that we incorporate into our life,
if not just for physical
performance reasons
and for postural reasons,
then also for cognitive
and mental reasons,
and I'll be sure to clarify
what all of that means.
Right now, I'd like to take a moment
and just highlight the
flexibility that you already have.
For instance, if you were to move your arm
behind your torso a little bit
and then sort of let go
or stop exerting any effort in doing that,
you would find that the limb would return
more or less to a position
next to your torso,
at least I would hope so.
And why is that?
Well, it turns out that there are aspects
of your nervous system, aspects
of your skeletal system,
aspects of your muscles,
and aspects of the connective tissue
that binds all of that together,
that try and restore a particular order
or position to your limbs
and your limbs relative to one another.
So, that reflects a very
specific set of processes
that it turns out are
the same set of processes
that you use when you are trying
to enhance flexibility and stretching.
So, I'd like to just take a moment
and review the basic
elements of nervous system,
muscle, connective tissue,
and skeletal tissue, bone,
that allow for flexibility and stretching.
And here we can point
to two major mechanisms
by which your nervous system,
neurons, meaning nerve cells,
communicate with muscles,
and those muscles communicate
back to your nervous system
to make sure that your
limbs don't stretch too far,
they don't move too far
such that you get injured.
And in addition to that,
mechanisms that ensure that
you don't overload your muscles
too much with weight, or
with tension, or with effort
and damage them that way.
'Cause it turns out that the
second security mechanism
of making sure that you
don't overload muscles
can be leveraged toward
increasing your flexibility
almost immediately.
That's right, there
are protocols and tools
that I'll share with you
that are going to allow you
to vastly improve your
flexibility over time.
But there are also
mechanisms that allow you
to quite significantly increase
your degree of flexibility
in a very short period of time,
and within just a few seconds.
So, let's establish some of the
basic biological mechanisms.
Any time we talk about
biology or physiology,
we're going to talk about structure,
meaning the cells and their connections,
and functions, what they do.
There are just a few names to understand,
you do not have to memorize these names.
The important thing that
I'd like you to know
is that flexibility and
the process of stretching
and getting more flexible
involves three major components,
neural, meaning of the nervous system,
muscular, muscles, and connective tissue.
Connective tissue is the stuff
that surrounds the neural
stuff and the muscular stuff,
although it's all kind of weaved together
and braided together in complicated ways.
Some of you may have heard of fascia.
We're going to talk a little
bit about fascia today,
although it's such an interesting tissue
that's really deserving
of its own episode.
Fascial tissue, we're going to
talk about some of the stuff
that surrounds muscles that
really gives you your shape,
and holds everything together,
and allows for flexibility to occur.
So, here's a key thing
that everyone should know
whether or not you're talking
about flexibility or not.
Your nervous system controls your muscles,
it's what gets your muscles to contract.
So, within your spinal cord,
you have a category of
neurons, nerve cells,
that are called motor neurons.
To be precise, they
are lower motor neurons
'cause they're in your spinal cord.
We call them lower to distinguish them
from the motor neurons
that are in your brain
up in your skull.
Those lower motor neurons,
hereafter I'll just refer
to them as motor neurons.
If I want to talk about the
other kind of motor neurons,
I'll say upper motor neurons.
So, if I say motor neurons,
I just mean the ones in your spinal cord.
Those motor neurons send a little wire
or set of wires out to your muscles,
and that creates what's called
a neuromuscular junction,
which just means that the
neurons meet the muscles
at a particular place.
Those neurons release a chemical,
that chemical is called acetylcholine.
Some of you may have heard
about acetylcholine before,
acetylcholine also exists in your brain
and does other things in your brain,
mainly it's involved
in focus and attention.
But at the neuromuscular junction,
the release of acetylcholine
from these nerve cells,
these neurons, onto the muscles
causes the muscles to contract.
And when muscles contract,
they are able to move limbs
by way of changing the
length of the muscle,
adjusting the function
of connective tissue
like tendons and ligaments.
And for instance,
if you're bringing your wrist
closer to your shoulder,
that biceps muscle is
contracting, it's getting shorter.
I mean, in reality it hasn't
gotten shorter overall,
it's just temporarily shorter, of course.
All of that is controlled by neurons.
And it's those motor
neurons from the spinal cord
that are really responsible
for the major movement
of your limbs by way
of causing contraction
of specific muscles at specific times.
So, the key thing to
take away is that nerve
controls the contraction of muscles.
Now, within the muscles themselves,
there are nerve connections.
And these are nerve connections that arise
from a different set of
neurons in the spinal cord
that we call sensory neurons.
The sensory neurons
exist in a different
part of the spinal cord,
and they send a low wire or
set of wires into the muscles.
And there's a particular
kind of sensory neuron
that comes out of your spinal
cord and into your muscles,
which are called spindle neurons.
They create or they actually
wrap around muscle fibers,
kind of corkscrew around them
and give kind of a spring-like appearance.
And for you aficionados out there,
these are intrafusal
connections or neurons.
Intrafusal means within the muscle,
but you really don't need to know that
unless you're really curious about it,
or you're going to
become a neuroscientist,
or you're in medical school or something.
These spindle connections
within the muscle
that wrap around the muscle fibers
sense the stretch of those muscle fibers.
So, now we have two parts to
the system that I've described.
You've got motor neurons
that can cause muscles
to contract and shorten,
and we have these spindles
within the muscles themselves
that wrap around the muscle fibers,
and that information
is sent from the muscle
back to the spinal cord.
It's a form of sensing what's
going on in the muscle.
Much in the same way that
you have neurons in your eye
that sense light in your
external environment,
you have neurons in your
ear that sense sound waves
in your external environment,
you have neurons in your spinal cord
that are sensory neurons
that are sensing the amount
of stretch in the muscles.
What happens is if a given
muscle is stretching really far,
those sensory neurons, those
spindles within the muscle
will activate and will send
a electrical potential,
literally a bit of electricity
along that wire's length
into the spinal cord.
And then, within the spinal cord
that sensory neuron communicates
through a series of intermediate steps,
but to the motor neuron
and makes sure that that
motor neuron contracts.
Now, why would that be useful?
Well, what this does is
it creates a situation
where if a muscle is or
is stretching too much
because the range of motion of
a limb is increased too much
then the muscle will contract
to bring that limb range of
motion into a safe range again.
Now, what determines whether
or not a range of motion
is quote-unquote safe or not
is dictated by a number of things.
It's dictated by things that are happening
in this kind of loop of neural connections
in the spinal cord and muscle.
It's also determined by
what's going on in your head,
literally in your mind cognitively
about whether or not the
movement of that limb
its increasing range of
motion is good for you,
whether or not you're
doing it deliberately,
whether or not it's bad for you.
And then there are also
some basic safety mechanisms
that are put in there that
really try and restrict
our limb range of motion.
Okay, so just to clarify,
this whole thing looks like a loop,
and the essential components of the loop
are motor neurons contract muscles,
sensory neurons, of
which there are a bunch
of different varieties,
well, in this case, what
we're calling the spindles
are sensing stretch within the muscles.
And if a given muscle is elongating
because of the increased
range of motion of a limb,
those sensory neurons
send an electrical signal
into the spinal cord
such that there is an
activation of the motor neuron,
which by now should make perfect sense
as to why that's useful.
It then shortens up the muscle.
It actually doesn't
really shorten the muscle,
but it contracts the muscle
that brings the limb back
into a safe range of motion.
Okay, so this process is very fast,
it was designed to keep
your body together and safe.
It's designed to make sure
that you don't take your arm
and swing it behind your torso
and it just goes all the way back
to the middle of your back.
I mean, unless you're a contortionist
or you've trained that kind
of level of flexibility,
that would be terrible
because it could provide a
lot of damage to the muscles,
and to the connective
tissue, and so forth.
So, that's one basic mechanism
that we want to hold in mind,
this idea of a spindle that senses stretch
and can activate
contraction of the muscles
and shorten the muscles.
The next mechanism I want to describe,
and once again there are only two
that you need to hold in
mind for this episode.
This other mechanism has
a lot of the same features
as the one I just described,
but it has less to do with stretch,
in fact, it doesn't
have to do with stretch
as much as it has to
do with sensing loads.
So, at the end of each muscles
you have tendons typically,
and there are neurons that
are closely associated
with those tendons
that are called Golgi
tendon organs, right?
These are neurons that are sensory neurons
that sense how much load
is on a given muscle.
Right, so if you're lifting
up something very, very heavy,
these neurons are going to fire,
meaning they're going to
send electrical activity
into the spinal cord.
And then, those neurons have
the ability to shut down,
not activate, but shut down motor neurons
and to prevent the
contraction of a given muscle.
So, for instance, if you were to walk over
and try and pick up a weight
that is much too heavy for you,
meaning you could not do it
without injuring yourself
and you start to try and heave
that weight off the ground.
There are a number of reasons
why you might not be able to lift it,
but let's say you start to get it
a little bit off the ground,
or you start to get some force generated
that would allow it to move.
But the force that you're generating
could potentially rip your
muscles or your tendons
off of the bone,
right, that it could disrupt the joints
and it could tear ligaments.
Well, you have a safety
mechanism in place,
it's these Golgi tendon organs,
these GTOs, as they're called,
they get activated and
shut down the motor neurons
and make it impossible for
those muscles to contract.
Okay, so on the one hand,
we have a mechanism that senses stretch
and can figure out when
stretch is excessive.
And when this system detects
that stretch is excessive,
it activates the contraction of muscles.
And then, we have a second
mechanism that senses loads,
and when tension or
loads is deemed excessive
by these circuits,
and remember these
circuits don't have a mind,
they don't go, "Oh, this is excessive,"
they just sense loads.
And when those loads
exceed a certain threshold,
well then those GTOs,
those Golgi tendon organs,
send signals into the spinal cord
that shut down your motor neuron's ability
to contract muscle so that
you no longer can lift
that heavy load.
So, both of these are
protective mechanisms,
but both of these can be
leveraged in a very logical way
and in a very safe way
in order to increase your
limb range of motion.
So, there are a couple of
things I want to point out
before going a little bit further
into how your nervous system
controls flexibility and stretching,
and those key points are the following.
There are now dozens if
not hundreds of studies
that show that a dedicated
stretching practice
can improve limb range of motion.
Now, for many of you listening,
you're probably saying, "Duh,"
but I think it's important
to point that out,
that a dedicated stretching practice
can increase limb range of motion.
And as you'll soon learn,
there are specific mechanisms
that can explain that effect.
The second point is one of longevity.
And when I say longevity,
I don't necessarily mean late-stage aging.
We all undergo a decrease
in limb range of motion,
unless we do something
to offset that decrease.
And the current numbers
vary from study to study,
but if you look en masse,
you look at all of those studies
and what you basically find
is that we start to experience
a decrease in flexibility
from about age 20 until about
age 49 that's pretty dramatic.
And then, of course, it
will continue after age 49,
but basically it's a 10%
decrease every 10 years.
So, we could say it's
a 1% decrease per year,
although it's not necessarily linear.
What do I mean by that?
Well, it's not necessarily
that on your 21st birthday,
you are 1% less flexible
than you were on your 20th birthday
and it decreased by 1% per year,
some of these changes can be non-linear.
So, you can imagine the person
who's doing just fine
in terms of flexibility
between 20 and 30,
and then they get to 32
and suddenly they've lost
5% of their flexibility.
Now, of course, there will be
a ton of lifestyle factors.
If you're a regular practitioner of yoga,
if you have a dedicated
stretching practice,
if you're doing other things
to improve your muscle contractibility,
so you're doing resistance training
it turns out can actually
indirectly improve flexibility.
There are a number of different factors,
but the key point is that maintaining
some degree of flexibility
and maybe even enhancing range
of motion and flexibility
is of immense benefit
for offsetting injury
provided it's not pushed too far.
There are a number of people
who have pushed their limb range of motion
so far that they experience
all sorts of injuries,
both acute and chronic injuries.
Today, we'll also talk about
how to avoid those scenarios.
Okay, so we've established
that there are mechanisms
within the spinal cord,
muscles, and connective tissue,
those remember it's the motor neurons,
the spindles, the GTOs,
and, of course, the muscles themselves,
and connective tissue, tendons,
but also other forms of connective tissue
that establish whether or not a limb
is going to stay within a
particular range of motion or not,
and whether or not a limb
is going to be allowed
by the nervous system to pursue
or handle a given load, a given tension.
There are also mechanisms that arrive
to the neuromuscular system
from higher up in the nervous
system, from the brain.
And those mechanisms involve
a couple of different facets
that are really interesting,
and I think that we should all know about.
In fact, today, I'm going to
teach you about a set of neurons
that I'm guessing 99.9% of
you have never heard of,
including all you
neuroscientists out there,
if you're out there, and
I know you're out there,
that seem uniquely enriched in humans
and probably perform essential roles
in our ability to regulate our physiology
and our emotional state.
So, within the brain,
we have the ability to sense
things in the external world,
something we called exteroception,
and we have the ability to sense things
in our internal world within
our body, called interoception.
Interoception can be the
volume of food in your gut,
whether or not you're experiencing
any organ pain or discomfort,
whether or not you feel good
in your gut and in your organs,
that's actually a kind of
feeling, "Hmm, I feel great,
I feel sated, I feel relaxed,"
but those are all different
forms of interoception.
The main brain area that's associated
with interpreting what's
going on in our body
is called the insula, I-N-S-U-L-A.
It's a very interesting brain region,
it's got two major parts.
The front of it is mainly
concerned with things like smell,
and to some extent vision, and
to some extent other things
that are arriving from the external world
and combining with what's
going on internally
and making sense of all that,
or at least routing that
information elsewhere
in your nervous system to make decision,
like if you smell something
good to approach it,
or if you smell something bad to avoid it.
The front of the insula is really doing
all of that kind of stuff
along with other brain areas.
The posterior insula, the
back of the insula that is,
has a very interesting and
distinct set of functions.
The posterior insula is mainly concerned
with what's going on with
your somatic experience.
How do you feel internally?
And how is the movement
that you happen to be doing
combining with your internal state
to allow you to feel,
as I like to say the nervous
system mainly batches things
into yum, like, "Oh, this
is really good for me,"
yuck, "This is really bad
for me and I need to stop,"
or meh, "This is kind of neutral."
Okay, so this isn't about food,
but we could say for most stimuli,
most senses, whether or not they're senses
of things internally or externally,
our nervous system is
trying to make decisions
about what to do with that information,
and so it mainly batches
information into yum,
I want to keep doing this
or approach this thing,
or continue down some path
of movement, or eating,
or staying in a temperature
environment, et cetera,
or yuck, I need to get out of here,
I don't want any more of this,
I don't want to keep doing this,
this is painful, or
aversive, or stressful.
And then meh, so if it
doesn't really matter,
I can just kind of stay right here or not.
Yum, yuck, and meh.
Well, in your posterior insula,
you have a very interesting population
of very large neurons,
these are exceptionally large neurons
called von Economo neurons.
These are neurons that are, again,
unbeknownst to most neuroscientists
and they seem uniquely enriched in humans.
Chimpanzees have them
and some other large animals have them.
So, they're found in whales,
chimpanzees, elephants, and in humans.
But even though we are much
smaller than most whales
and even though we are much
smaller than most elephants,
I mean, remember there are baby elephants.
As far as I know, they haven't bred up
like mini-elephants yet,
they seem to have a teacup version
of pretty much every dog breed.
You can look that up,
I certainly have mixed
feelings about this notion
of trying to downsize everything
to the point where you could
kind of like the pocket-sized bulldog
I think of someday will arrive.
I'm not a fan of that kind of downsizing
of different breeds,
but because there aren't teacup elephants
and teacup gorillas, and teacup
chimpanzees, and so forth,
most all of those other
species are larger than us.
They have these von Economo neurons
and we have these von Economo neurons,
but we have in upwards
of 80,000 of these things
in our posterior insula.
These other species tend to have
somewhere in the range of
1,000 to maybe 10,000 or so.
Why is that interesting?
Well, these von Economo neurons
have the unique property of integrating
our knowledge about our body movements,
our sense of pain and discomfort,
and can drive motivational processes
that allow us to lean into discomfort
and, indeed, to overcome any discomfort
if we decide that the discomfort
that we are experiencing
is good for us or directed
toward a specific goal.
This knowledge turns out
to be very important to keep in mind
because as we migrate this conversation
toward the things that we can do
to enhance flexibility and stretching,
you'll soon learn that there are moments
within a stretching protocol
where you have the opportunity
to either override pain
and discomfort to kind of relax through it
or push through it.
Right, there's a decision
fork in the road there,
and it'll tell you which
fork in the road to take,
or to say, "Uh-uh, I'm
not going to do that.
I'm going to allow these natural reflexes
of the spindle to kick in
and just essentially
stop me from stretching
if a given limb isn't designed
or shouldn't be stretched that far."
So, I'd like you to keep these
von Economo neurons in mind.
I should mention they're named von Economo
because the guy, Constantin von Economo,
that discovered them at the
end of the 1800s, early 1900s,
decided to name them after
himself, as many scientists do,
or certainly the
neurologists and physicians
are famous for naming
things after themselves.
These von Economo neurons
turn out to be very
important to keep in mind
as we embark on our exploration
of what sorts of stretching practices
can be best applied to
increase flexibility
because whether or not
you undertake a mild,
moderate, or intense flexibility training,
you will no doubt encounter
a scenario at some point
where you will have to ask
yourself, "Do I quote-unquote
relax into this stretch,
or do I try and push through
just a little bit of discomfort?"
And I'll explain how
to gauge that decision
in a very specific and ideally safe way,
and I'll give you some
tools that will allow you
to make that decision in a way
that best preserves the integrity
of those neural circuits
that I described earlier
and can keep you safe.
These von Economo neurons
sit in the exact position
that one would want to be able to evaluate
what's going on in the body,
in particular what's going on
in terms of limb movements,
how that relates to our
feelings of discomfort.
And then there's the other aspect
of these von Economo neurons,
which is that these von Economo neurons
are connected to a number
of different brain areas
that can shift our internal state
from one of so-called
sympathetic activation.
So, this is a pattern of
alertness and even stress,
sometimes even panic,
but typically alertness and stress
to one of so called
parasympathetic activation
to one of relaxation.
Oftentimes, you'll hear that stretching
should be done by
relaxing into the stretch.
Well, what does it actually
mean to relax into the stretch?
Well, these von Economo neurons
sit at this junction where
they're able to evaluate
what's going on inside our body
and allow us to access neural circuitries
by which we can shift our
relative level of alertness
down a bit, or our relative
level of stress down a bit
and thereby to increase so-called
parasympathetic activation
and to literally override some
of those spindle mechanisms,
even the GTO mechanisms,
but especially the spindle mechanisms
at the neuromuscular and
muscular spinal junction.
And in that way,
gently, subtly override the reflex
that would otherwise cause us
to contract those muscles back.
The reason that's possible
is because your brain
has those other kinds of motor neurons,
the upper motor neurons
that can both direct,
meaning control, and can
override lower motor neurons.
I'll give you a brief example of this
that you've already done in your life,
and that we all have the capacity for.
What I'm referring to is the
monosynaptic stretch reflex.
This is something that every
first year neuroscience
graduate student learns,
which is that if you were to step
on a sharp object with a bare foot,
you would not need to make the decision
to retract your foot, you
would automatically do that
provided you have a
healthy nervous system.
There are mechanisms in place
that cause the retraction of that limb
by way of ensuring that
the proper muscles contract
and other muscles do not contract,
in fact, that they fully relax.
Okay, so in the case of
stepping on a sharp object
like a piece of glass,
or a nail, or a tack,
you would essentially
activate the hip flexor
to lift up your foot
as quickly as possible.
In doing so, that same neural circuit
would activate a contralateral,
meaning opposite side of the body circuit,
to ensure that the leg,
the foot that's not
stepping on the sharp object
would do exactly the
opposite and would extend
to make sure that you don't fall over.
All of that happens reflexively,
it does not require any
thought or decision making.
In fact, humans without any neocortex,
literally that who decerebrate
or an animal that doesn't have...
When I say decerebrate, I
mean lack of cerebral cortex.
They can perform that
because it's all controlled by circuits
that are basically below the
brain and in the spinal cord.
There's a little bit of
activation of circuits
in the kind of deeper parts of the brain,
but basically you don't need to think
or decide in order to do that.
However, if your life depended
on walking across some
sharp objects, let's say.
Let's make it a little less dramatic
so it's not like the "Die
Hard" movie or something
where he has to run
barefoot across the glass,
although that's a pretty good example
of what I'm describing here,
but let's say you had to walk
across some very hot stones
to get away from something
that you wanted to avoid.
You could override that stretch reflex
by way of a decision made
with your upper motor neurons,
your insula, and your cognition,
and almost certainly
those von Economo neurons,
which would be screaming, "Don't do this,
don't do this, don't do this,"
could shuttle that
information to brain areas
that would allow you
to override the reflex
and essentially push through the pain.
And maybe even, in fact,
even not experience the pain
to the same degree or even at all.
So, these von Economo neurons
sit at a very important
junction within the brain.
They pay attention to what's
going on in your body,
pain, pleasure, et cetera.
And that includes what's
going on with your limbs
and your limb range of motion.
They also are paying attention
and can control the amount of activation,
kind of alertness or calmness
that you are able to
create within your body
in response to a given sensory experience.
And as I mentioned before,
they seem to be uniquely
enriched in humans,
they seem to be related to
the aspects of our evolution
that allow us to make decisions
about what to do with our body
in ways that other
animals just simply can't.
Before we go any further,
I want to give you a practical tool
that you can, of course, use,
but that will also give
you insight and experience
into your muscle spindle
spinal cord circuit mechanisms.
So, what I'd like you to do
is if you're in a proper place to do this,
you're going to stand with legs straight,
meaning knees not bent,
and you're going to try
and touch your toes,
or for some of you that's
going to be very easy
and you might even be
able to put your hands
flat on the floor.
I don't have that kind of flexibility,
it's pretty easy for me to touch my toes.
I don't care if you
round your back or not,
although ideally I would
say don't round your back.
Not because it's bad to do so necessarily,
but just to try and keep this
the same from trial to trial, as it were.
So, try and get a sense of
what your range of motion
is in terms of bending over at the waist
while maintaining a flat back
and trying to touch your
toes or even touch the floor.
Maybe, again, you can even
go hands flat to the floor
or maybe even far out in front of you.
Okay, now what I'd like
you to do is stand back up
and I'd like you to
contract your quadriceps
as hard as you possibly
can for about 5-15 seconds.
Let's say 10 seconds
just to keep things
more or less normalized.
This obviously is not a
super controlled experiment.
So, to contract your quadriceps
for those of you who don't know,
you're going to extend
your lower limb out.
So, this would be like kicking,
although don't do it too quickly,
you're going to kick out your foot,
you should feel your quadriceps contract
on the top of your thighs.
And you're going to try and
consciously contract them
as hard as you can.
Okay, typically if you
want to point your toe
back towards your knee or
shin that's also going to help
somewhat to contract
even harder and harder.
Okay, so, do that for about 10 seconds.
A lot of you will do
this just while standing,
contract, contract, contract.
Okay, then release it,
and then now go ahead
and repeat that stretch
where you're trying to touch
your toes or touch the floor.
So, this is, again, relying more or less
on hamstring flexibility
among other things.
Okay, what most of you will find
is that you have an immediate increase
in hamstring flexibility,
or your range of motion has increased.
If you didn't experience that,
then I would encourage you
to try and contract your
quadriceps harder and longer,
so maybe 20 or 30 seconds,
and then try this
so-called experiment again.
Why would contracting your quadriceps
allow your hamstring flexibility
to suddenly increase?
Well, the way that our
muscles are organized
is such that we have muscles
that are antagonistic to one another.
So, our quadriceps and our hamstrings
work in sort of a push-pull
fashion, if you will.
They can antagonize one another,
so when you move your
heel towards your glutes,
you are using your hamstring,
the hamstring obviously
also does other things
related to hip movement.
And when you lift your knee
or when you extend your foot
and contract your quadriceps,
you are essentially
relaxing the hamstrings.
Now, of course, most movements
involve both quadricep and
hamstring in synchrony.
And that synchrony is
really an elegant one,
but here we're more or less isolating
the quadriceps from the hamstrings,
at least to the extent
that it can leverage
these spindle stretch mechanisms.
So, what happens is when you
contract your quadriceps hard,
you are relaxing or
releasing some of the stretch
that's occurring in those
intrafusal spindle sensory fibers
going into your spinal cord.
And as a consequence,
you're able then to stretch
your hamstrings further,
or we can be more accurate and
say that your range of motion
about the hamstring and its related joints
is greater when you aren't
engaging that spindle reflex,
which would cause the
hamstrings to contract.
Okay, so if you are somebody
who has tight hamstrings,
there could be a variety
of reasons for that,
but part of the reason
is likely to be neural
and you can release that
neural spindle reflex
by contracting the opposite
antagonistic muscle,
which in this case is the quadriceps.
The same thing is true
and can be leveraged
for stretching other muscles.
So, for instance, if you're
going to do a tricep stretch,
the typical kind of overhead
where you grab your elbow
and move it toward the
midline of your body
with using your opposite hand.
Well, you can do that,
and then I would suggest
trying to flex your bicep,
contract your bicep that
is, while doing that.
And for most people
you'll notice a increase
in the tricep range of motion
or ability to kind of lean into,
or to relax into, or to push that stretch,
excuse me, a little bit further.
Now, for you physios out there
and for those of you that have
backgrounds in kinesiology,
I want to acknowledge,
of course, there are other mechanisms
that are coming into play.
There are actually neural connections
within the joints themselves
that are providing
proprioceptive feedback,
et cetera, et cetera.
But this is simply to illustrate
that part of our range of motion
is determined by these spindle mechanisms
that I spent some time
focusing on earlier.
And indeed, this approach can be leveraged
toward creating increased
limb range of motion,
not just for the hamstrings,
but for your quadriceps.
So, for instance, if you
have tight quadriceps,
you can do the opposite.
You can contract your
hamstring very intensely
for let's say 10 seconds, or
20 seconds, or 30 seconds.
So, that would take some conscious effort
of bringing your heel
up towards your glutes.
You could do that in a way
that you're really trying to
contract those muscles hard,
you'd have to use some deliberate
hamstring activation there,
meaning you have to use
those upper motor neurons
and the other aspects of your
upper brain power, as it were,
to try and really contract your hamstrings
as intensely as possible,
then you would relax that,
and then you would do your
quadricep stretch again.
And if you did a pre-hamstring contraction
measurement of your quadricep flexibility,
and then you did a
post-hamstring contraction
measure of your quadricep flexibility,
almost certainly you would find
that that flexibility had increased.
Now, of course, the muscle
really didn't change much,
the tendons didn't change much.
What changed was the
patterns of neural activation
that were restricting you
from in the first case
stretching your hamstring or having a...
To be more accurate we should say
having a certain range of
motion about the hamstring
and its related joints
and those brake mechanisms were removed.
And, of course, then when
you contract your hamstring,
you're removing some of the neural brakes,
the spindle acting as a brake
and inhibiting that
quadricep range of motion.
Okay, so you can imagine this,
and in fact you can apply this
for any number of different muscles,
the larger muscles and the sort of biceps,
triceps, and hamstrings, quadriceps
that are sort of the simplest
place to think about this
and to apply it.
But in theory and, indeed, in practice,
it really works for all
the various muscle groups,
it's just sometimes harder to access
these so-called
antagonistic muscle groups.
Now, we should take a
moment and just discuss
what actually happens
as we get more flexible
in the short-term and long-term.
I just mentioned what
happens in the short-term,
clearly those don't involve
lengthening of the muscles.
It's not like the muscles
slide along the bones
or that the tendons really stretch out
that much more than they had
prior to that kind of exercise.
But it is the case that if people stretch
consistently over a given
period of several weeks or more
that there are changes in the muscles.
This gets a little bit tricky
in terms of nomenclature,
and I just want to highlight that
because I think that a number of people
get frustrated and confused,
in fact, when we talk about
muscles getting longer.
You know, that the whole concept
of a muscle getting longer
isn't really in keeping with reality,
but there are elements within the muscles
that can change their confirmation.
So, to get a little bit detailed here,
and we won't spend too much time on this,
but I just want to acknowledge this
for those of you that are interested
in neuromuscular physiology
and how it relates to flexibility.
You know, you have your muscle fibers
and then you have your
so-called myofibrils.
So, you can imagine
kind of a single fiber,
that fiber, of course, will get input
from those motor neurons.
And then within those fibers,
you have what are called sarcomeres.
And you can kind of think about sarcomeres
as little segments, kind of
like the segments of bamboo.
If you ever look at bamboo,
it's not just one big stalk,
it's got those little
outpouching along the way
that going to break up
the what would be just
one big stalk of bamboo
into different segments,
but they're all connected.
The sarcomeres are somewhat like that.
And within the sarcomeres
you have a couple of different components.
One thing is called myosin,
which is like a thick layer,
and then the other is actin.
And those are interdigitated, as we say,
they're kind of connected to one another,
kind of like if you were
put your fingers together
from your two hands.
If you put your fingers
in between one another,
that's interdigitated,
literally interdigitated in
this case, so pun intended.
And that myosin and actin
kind of move relative to one another
and they have a lot to
do with your ability
to contract muscles.
When we stretch muscles,
when we go through a stretching practice,
there are a number of things that change,
some neural, some related
directly to connective tissue,
but also it appears from really nice work
mainly done from McGill University,
I'll provide a link to a
couple of these studies
if you want to dig in there more deeply,
that change the confirmation,
the relative size and spacing
of some of these things
like sarcomeres and the
way that myosin and actin
kind of work together.
But we don't want to think
of muscles as lengthening,
we can, however, think about
the resting state of a muscle
being slightly different
or, indeed, very different
than the resting state of a muscle
of somebody or of a limb
that has not undergone
regular flexibility training.
So, that's as much time
as I want to spend on that
because we could spend an entire hour
getting right down into the details,
but I do want to emphasize, however,
that muscles have different
parts, they have fibers,
they have sarcomeres, they
have myosin, they have actin.
But the idea of making our muscles longer,
that reflects a number of processes
that occur basically within
an existing muscle length.
The length of our muscle bellies
and where our insertions are relative
to our connective tissue in our limbs
is genetically determined, right?
Some people have, for instance,
a bicep that goes all the way
from the crook of their elbow
up to their shoulder, right?
And some people can if
they were to put their arm
in a 90 degree angle could
put two or three fingers
between their bicep and their elbow.
They have, we can say, a shorter
bicep, relatively shorter.
Now, the reason I mentioned
these highly detailed cellular mechanisms
is because as we start to
embark on different protocols
for using stretching
to increase flexibility
and range of motion,
we need to ask ourselves what
is preventing our ability
to extend range of motion?
Is it the spindle, right?
Is it because the muscle
is stretching too much?
Oftentimes, it can be because of that
and/or because of a sense of pain
or simply a sense that the
muscle is not in a position
that it's been in before
that's unrelated to pain
or to spindle activation.
And oftentimes, it can be related directly
to these changes in the
confirmation of myosin and actin,
and within the context of the sarcomeres.
Now, of course, you can't peer into
or sense your individual sarcomeres,
however, you do have neurons
that innovate these areas
and that send that sensory information
back into the spinal cord and
up to your brain to interpret.
So, you'll find that as we move along,
there are specific
adjustments that you can make
at both the macro level,
meaning how much movement to insert
into your stretching, right?
Is it going to be a static,
or a dynamic, or even a ballistic stretch?
Or, for instance, at the micro level,
that even just a slight sub-millimeter
or millimeter increase in the
stretching of a given muscle
and it related tissues
can translate into an increased
range of motion performance.
As a quick but relevant aside,
I thought I'd share with
you something useful
that's also grounded in this
notion of antagonistic muscles.
So, for those of you that
do resistance training,
whether or not it's with body weight,
or with physical weights,
or machines, what have you,
you may have found that if you,
let's say, were to do three
sets of a pushing exercise,
so this could be pushups,
this could be bench presses,
this could be shoulder presses,
something of that sort.
And then, later in the
workout you were to do,
let's say, machine
pull-downs, or pull-ups,
or chin-ups of some sort,
so a pulling exercise.
Typically, what you would find
is if you were to do what's
often called straight sets,
so you would do three sets of pushups,
let's say, with two
minutes of rest in between
that you might be able to get
a certain number of
repetitions on the first set.
Let's just for sake of example,
let's say you can get 10
repetitions on the first set,
and then you get eight
repetitions on the second set,
and then you get six
repetitions on the third set
with two minutes in between,
and then you would move on at some point
to your pulling exercises.
And similarly, let's say
you were doing chin-ups
or pull-downs and you
would get 10 repetitions,
rest two minutes,
eight repetitions, rest two
minutes, and six repetitions.
Okay, fine.
Well, typically what people discover
is that if they interleave
their pushing and pulling exercises,
provided they do that for muscles
that are antagonistic to one another.
So, in this case, pushing with the chest,
shoulders, and triceps
for the pushing exercises,
and pulling with the back and biceps,
and, of course, there are
other muscles involved as well.
But because those muscle groups
are at least in part
antagonistic to one another,
what people often find
is that if they were
to, say, do their pushing
set, get 10 repetitions,
then move to a pulling set
after just say 60 seconds
and perform that pulling set,
then go back to the pushing set,
then go back to a pulling set,
push, pull, push, pull,
in other words, interleaving their sets.
Even if they were to maintain
the same amount of rest
between sets of pushing
and sets of pulling,
what they discover often is that the drop
in the number of repetitions that they get
is somewhat offset.
So, rather than get 10, 8, 6,
as it were with the straight sets,
it will be 10, 9, 8.
So, what this means is
not that you're increasing
the total rest time to
four minutes between sets
because then, of course,
it wouldn't be equivalent,
but rather that while maintaining
the same amount of rest
between sets for this same muscle group,
by going from push, pull, push, pull
of antagonistic muscles,
you're able to have improved performance.
And the reason for that
has everything to do
with what we were describing before,
which is that typically if
you were to do push set,
rest, push set, rest, push set, rest.
Well, in between those sets
and, in fact, actually
during those sets of pushing,
the pulling muscles that would
be involved in the chin-ups
or pull-downs, et cetera,
are actually relaxing,
or at least are being
released of some tension,
including the activation of the
spindles among other things.
So, that's a long-winded way of saying
that interleaving push and
pull of antagonistic sets
can leverage some of
the same neural circuits
that we're talking about leveraging
for sake of increasing flexibility.
Now, I offer this to you
as a tool that you can try.
One of the challenges
with using this tool,
however, is that you often
have to occupy multiple sites
within the gym.
You know, if you're doing this at home
and you have your own
gym, that's one thing.
If you're doing this in a gym
where you have multiple
pieces of equipment,
well, then you become that person
who has essentially taken
over some small corner,
or multiple corners, or
machines within the gym.
And oftentimes, you'll
find that you'll walk back
to a machine or you'll walk back
to a given resistance exercise
and someone has now taken it over
and the whole thing could be thrown off.
So, it takes a little bit of orchestrating
in order to do properly.
But in general, what people find
is that this can allow you to
enhance performance overall
of these individual movements,
again, while maintaining
the same amount of rest.
And even if you choose not to do this,
I encourage you to pay
attention to this as a concept
because, again, it's leveraging this idea
of antagonistic muscles,
flexors and extensors,
antagonistic neural relationships
between the spinal cord mechanisms
that control one set of muscles
and activating those muscles,
allowing the opposite
antagonistic muscle to relax
and therefore to perform
better on its next set.
So, now I'd like to shift to the question
of what types of stretching
can and should we do
to increase limb range of motion?
If our goal is to do that
in the most efficient way possible
'cause I realize that most people
don't have endless amounts of time
to dedicate to a stretching practice.
And even for those of us that do,
I'm sure that you want
to get the most outcome
for a given effort.
And what are the modes of stretching
that are going to allow us
to increase our flexibility
and limb range of motion most safely?
Now, there are a number of
different types of stretching
or methods of stretching.
Broadly defined, we can
describe these as dynamic,
ballistic, static, and
what's called PNF stretching.
PNF stands for Proprioceptive
Neuromuscular Facilitation,
and it involves and leverages
many of the mechanisms
that I described to you earlier.
The first two that I mentioned,
dynamic and ballistic stretching,
both involves some degree of momentum,
and can be distinguished
from static and PNF-type stretching.
Now, to distinguish dynamic stretching
from ballistic stretching,
I'd like to focus on
this element of momentum.
Both involve moving a limb
through a given range of motion,
in dynamic stretching, however,
it tends to be more controlled,
less use of momentum,
especially towards the
end range of motion.
Whereas in ballistic stretching,
there tends to be a bit
more swinging of the limb
or use of momentum.
So, I invite you to visualize what dynamic
and ballistic stretching
might look like in your mind,
you can even try it if it's
safe for you to try it.
You know, you could imagine
swinging your arm up overhead
as much as possible and bringing it down.
I'm doing this because I'm seated,
it's kind of a ridiculous
movement to do while seated
or perhaps at all.
But for instance,
you can see dynamic and
ballistic stretching.
Anytime someone, for instance,
is holding onto something
with one arm or maybe not holding on
and swinging out their foot,
so essentially getting
movement about the hip joint.
And you'll notice that
some people raise it up,
and pause it, and bring it down,
that's one form of dynamic stretching.
Whereas others will swing it up
and sort of let it carry
itself a bit further
due to the momentum at
the top of the movement,
and then just let it drop back down
or maybe even control the descent.
There is an enormous range
of parameter space here
or variables that one could imagine,
and there's just simply no way
that we could subdivide all those.
But again, dynamic and
ballistic stretching
both involve movement,
so we have to generate some force
in order to create that movement.
Ballistic stretching
involving a bit more momentum
or sometimes a lot more momentum,
especially at the end range of of motion.
Now, both of those are highly distinct
from static stretching,
which involves holding
the end range of motion,
so minimizing the amount
of momentum that's used.
So, to stay with the simple example
that we are all now familiar with
from our earlier discussion,
slowly bending over at the waist
and trying to touch your toes
or putting your hands to the floor
and then holding that end position
before coming up in a
slow and controlled way,
such that you reduce the
amount of momentum to near zero
would be one example of static stretching.
Static stretching can
be further subdivided
into active or passive.
Right, there are different names
for these kinds of approaches.
You can hear about the Anderson approach
or the Jander approach,
you can look these sorts
of things up online.
And, again, people tend to
name things after themselves,
so some of these are proprietary
related to specific programs,
I'm not focusing on those.
Others come to be named
after the physiologists
or the practitioners that
initially popularize them.
As is always the case,
there's always a naming and renaming
and claiming of territory
with these things.
For the time being, I'd
like to just emphasize
that static stretching can be both active,
where there's a dedicated effort
on the part of the stretcher, you,
to put force behind the
hold to kind of extend
or literally to extend
the range of motion.
And then, there's also
passive static stretching
in which it's more of a relaxation
into a further range of motion,
and that can be a subtle distinction.
And there are other ways in
which we can further distinguish
active and passive static stretching.
But nonetheless, static stretching
involves both those types of
elements, active and passive,
but is really about eliminating momentum.
And then, there's the PNF,
the Proprioceptive
Neuromuscular Facilitation.
And proprioception has
several different meanings
in the context of
neuroscience and physiology.
To just keep it really simple for today,
proprioception involves both
a knowledge and understanding
of where our limbs are in
space and relative to our body.
Typically, relative to the midline,
so the brain is often trying to figure out
where are our limbs
relative to our midline
down the center of our body.
And we know where our limbs are
based on so-called
proprioceptive feedback,
so that's feedback that
comes from sensory neurons.
Right, now you know what sensory neurons
that are essentially monitoring
or responding to events within the joints,
the connective tissue, and the muscles,
and within the deep
components of the muscles
like the spindle reflex,
and within the tendons like the GTO,
the Golgi tendon organ.
So, PNF-type stretching
leverages these sorts of
mechanisms, these neural circuits,
by way of, for instance,
you would lie on your back
and if your goal is to increase
your hamstring flexibility
and the flexibility and range of motion
of other related muscle systems,
you might put a strap around your ankle
and pull that muscle.
Or I should say, excuse
me, that limb towards you,
you're not going to pull
the muscle towards you,
you're going to pull that
limb your ankle towards you
to try and get it sort
of back over your head.
And then, progressively
relaxing into that,
or maybe even putting
some additional force
to push the end range of
motion and then relaxing it.
And then, actually trying
to stretch that same limb
or increase the limb range
of motion without the strap.
Right, sometimes these are
assisted by other people.
So, people will even use loads,
sometimes they'll even use machines.
There are a number of different apparati
that have been designed for this,
sometimes it'll involve
a training partner.
There's a huge range of PNF protocols,
and those protocols can
be done both by oneself
with or without straps, with machines,
with actual weights, or
with training partners.
If you're interested in
the variation of exercises
to, say, target your hamstrings
versus your quadriceps
versus your shoulders versus
your chest muscles, et cetera,
your neck muscles, and so on,
there is an enormous range of information
on dynamic, ballistic,
static, and PNF stretches
for all the various muscle groups.
And I should say there
are some excellent books
on those topics,
there are also some excellent videos
on YouTube and elsewhere.
Nowadays, it's pretty
easy to find exercises
that allow you to target
specific muscle groups.
Again, I encourage you to be
safe in how you approach this,
and I would encourage
you also to pay attention
to the information that soon follows
as to what sorts of
protocols one would use
to apply those exercises.
But the number of exercises
and the availability of those exercises
for targeting different muscle groups
with these four different
kinds of stretching
is both immense and
fortunately, thankfully,
immediately accessible to
all of us often at zero cost.
So, specific exercises
to target specific muscle groups aside,
we've now established
that there are four major
categories of stretching,
or at least those are
the four major categories
I'm defining today.
And we can further divide those categories
into which are the ones that
are going to be most effective
for increasing range of
motion in the long-term,
not just in one individual session.
And there have been a number
of studies exploring this.
I can list out at least four,
and we'll put those four
as a kind of a cluster
under one heading in
the show note captions
that arrive at essentially
the same answer,
which is that for increasing
limb range of motion,
it does appear that static type,
including PNF, but static-type stretching
is going to be more effective
than dynamic and ballistic stretching.
So, at least in my
mind, this is good news.
Why is it good news to me?
Well, while dynamic and
ballistic stretching
can be immensely useful
for improving performance
of specific movements,
in particular, in the
context of particular sports
like tennis, or in sprinting,
or frankly for any sport,
they do carry with them
a certain amount of risk
because of the use of momentum.
So, you don't need to be highly trained
in order to perform them.
In fact, there is a place
and we will describe when one
would want to apply dynamic
or ballistic stretching.
I'll just give away for now,
I think that most physios out there
and certainly the ones that I spoke to,
Dr. Andy Galpin, Dr. Kelly
Starrett, and a few others
point to the fact that doing some safe
dynamic and ballistic stretching
prior to, say, a resistance
training session,
or maybe even prior to a
cardiovascular training session
can be useful both in terms
of range of motion effects
and in terms of neural activation effects.
I don't want to use the words warm-up
because warming up is typically associated
with increasing core body
temperature, as it should be,
but for engaging the neural circuits
and becoming familiarized
with the neural circuits
that you're about to
use in other movements
while also increasing the
range of motion of the joints
involved in those movements
so that you can perform them more safely
and more confidently.
So, I'm certainly not saying,
I want to repeat, I'm certainly not saying
that dynamic and ballistic
stretching are not useful,
they absolutely are,
but in terms of increasing
limb range of motion
in the long-term of truly
becoming more flexible
as opposed to transiently more flexible,
static stretching, which includes PNF,
appears to be the best route to go.
So, if your goal is to increase
your limb range of motion
for a given muscle group, or
perhaps for all muscle groups,
although you can imagine
that'd be pretty tough.
I mean, you're not going to spend time,
I could imagine, working on
your tongue muscle control
or neck muscle control
and every muscle control,
but most of us want to
reduce so-called tightness
in air quotes and increase
limb range of motion
for certain muscle groups.
And it appears that
the best way to do that
is going to be static
stretching of some kind,
which raises the question of how often
to do that static stretching
and how long to hold
those static stretches.
And we can also ask the question,
we should ask the question,
where to hold those static stretches?
Is it always a good idea to
hold those static stretches
at the end or the point of
maximal range of motion?
We're going to address that now.
There's some terrific science around this.
A slightly older study,
but nonetheless a powerful one
because it provided a foundation
for a lot of subsequent work,
which basically served to just confirm
the answer they got here is
a study from Bandy et al.
And the title of this study
is The Effect of Time and
Frequency of Static Stretching
on the Flexibility of
the Hamstring Muscles.
It was a study involving 93 subjects,
so 61 men, 32 women ranging
an age from 21-39 years,
so a pretty broad demographic
who had limited hamstring
muscle flexibility,
here I'm paraphrasing,
and randomly assigned
to one of five groups.
So, the four stretching groups
stretched five days
per week for six weeks,
the fifth group, which served
as a control, did not stretch.
The results clearly show that quote,
"The change in flexibility
appeared to be dependent
on the duration and
frequency of stretching."
This is great,
this tells us that stretching
for a given amount of time
scales with the amount
of limb range of motion
improvement that one will see.
There were many interesting
findings within this study,
but the one that I'd like
to highlight most is quote,
"The results of this study
suggest that a 30 second duration
is an effective amount of time
to sustain a hamstring muscle stretch
in order to increase range of motion.
No increase in flexibility occurred
when the duration of
stretching was increased
from 30 seconds to 60 seconds,
or when the frequency of
stretching was increased
from one to three times per day."
Okay, so now we're starting
to lay down some parameters.
What this study reveals and
what subsequent studies tell us,
and we will get into
those subsequent studies,
is that ideally one
would do static stretches
that are held for 30 seconds.
Perhaps more in certain instances,
and I'll explain when that can be useful,
but here holding those stretches
for more than 30 seconds
did not turn out to be
additionally useful.
So, if you're going to stretch
your quadricep, for instance,
and you're going to hold that
stretch in static fashion,
remember not using momentum,
and you can use the mental tricks
of either trying to push through the pain,
which I don't recommend necessarily,
I think that makes us prone to injury,
or to relax into the stretch,
but nonetheless providing some force
typically with a hand in
order to pull your ankle back,
if you're doing a quadricep stretch,
some people might do this
on the edge of a sofa.
Remember, there are a lot
of different exercises
and ways to do this that
you can explore elsewhere.
Well, holding that static
stretch for 30 seconds
appears to be sufficient
to stimulate an increase in
limb range of motion over time.
Again, these are protocols
that were used repeatedly over time,
and we'll talk about
how often to repeat them
in order to get maximal effect.
But 30-second holds for static stretches
is the number that I
think we want to focus on
and that most of us are
going to want to utilize.
So, now let's explore how
many sets of static stretching
one ought to do in order to get
a maximum range of motion improvement
while not placing us into a system
that's going to create injury
nor a situation where we have
to be constantly stretching
throughout the day
because, again, most of us
don't have time to do that.
This issue of sets is an important one.
In the context of cardiovascular exercise,
we've talked about the
data that support the fact
that doing at least 150
and ideally as much as
200 minutes per week
of Zone 2 cardiovascular exercise
is very useful for cardiovascular health
and for other aspects of health.
And, of course, there are other aspects
of cardiovascular exercise
that could be layered onto and into that
that can be useful like 90 second
maximal sprints, et cetera.
Discussed this a lot in the
episode with Dr. Andy Galpin
and on our episode about endurance.
And we also talked about sets
in the context of strength
and hypertrophy building,
building muscle size and/or strength
in the episode about that.
And in particular, in the
episode with Dr. Andy Galpin,
and there, we could also arrive
at some specific parameters.
And it's going to vary, of
course, between individuals,
depending on how hard you train,
whether or not you take sets to failure,
your repetition range, et cetera,
but in the context of strength
and hypertrophy building,
we arrived at a approximately six,
maybe as many as 10 sets
per week per muscle group.
Some of that work is done as direct work
to a given muscle group, some
of that work is indirect.
So, doing certain pulling exercise,
of course, will target the
latissimus dorsi muscles,
but also the biceps.
So, that doesn't necessarily
mean you have to do 10 sets
for the biceps and for the lats,
sometimes you're getting some
indirect work, et cetera.
All of that was delineated in the episode
with Dr. Andy Galpin.
And we arrived at those numbers of sets
according to the same criteria
that we will apply here,
what is the minimum number of sets
both to maintain and to improve
a given mode of performance?
Strength and hypertrophy
or cardiovascular health,
again, to either maintain or improve.
And we can do the same thing for improving
or maintaining range of motion
because as I mentioned earlier,
the data pointed to the fact
that if we don't do some dedicated work
to improve range of motion over time,
we will lose our flexibility
and limb range of motion over time
just by virtue of the fact
that we're not doing
anything to offset that.
So, whether or not you want to maintain,
reestablish, or gain limb range of motion,
static stretching of holds of
30 seconds appear to be best.
Now, the question is how
long should you do that?
And how many sets should you do that?
And how many times a
week should you do that?
And to answer those questions,
I'm going to turn to what I think
is a really spectacular review.
This was a review that was
published in the year 2018,
so it's fairly recent,
first author Thomas, Ewan Thomas,
last author Palma.
We will put a link to this
in the show note caption.
The title of the paper
is The Relation Between
Stretching Typology
and Stretching Duration: The
Effects on Range of Motion.
It's a very straightforward title.
This is a review article that explored
a number of different studies,
had criteria for whether
or not those studies
could be evaluated in the
context of the questions here,
had some quality standards
and some other standards
that they applied.
And basically, windowed down
a large collection of studies
to a remaining 23 articles
that were able to be
considered quote, "Eligible
and included in the quantitative
synthesis done here."
So, key points from that quantification
and synthesis done in this paper.
First of all, and I quote,
"All stretching typologies
showed range of motion improvements
over a long-term period.
However, the static protocols
showed significant gains
with a p-value less than .05,"
which means a probability
that cannot be explained
by chance alone,
"When compared to ballistic
or PNF protocols."
So, again, that we're hearing
is that static stretching
is the preferred mode for
increasing limb range of motion.
Although, here they make
the additional point
that static stretching
might even be superior,
not just to ballistic stretching,
but also to PNF protocols.
Because before, as you may recall,
there was a distinction
between ballistic and dynamic,
and static and PNF.
And so, here it appears
again that static stretching
is sort of rising to the top of the list
as the optimal approach
relative to all other
stretching approaches,
at least in the context of
increasing limb range of motion.
The authors go on to say,
"Time spent stretching per week
seems fundamental to elicit
range of movement improvements
when stretches are applied
for at least or more
than five minutes per week."
Okay, this is critical.
This is not five minutes per stretch.
Remember, 30 seconds per static stretch,
but at least five minutes per week.
Whereas the time spent stretching
within a single session
does not seem to have a significant effect
for range of motion gains.
If this is getting confusing,
I'll make sure that you soon understand
exactly what we can export
from these conclusions.
The data indicated that
performing stretching
at least five days a week.
Now, some of you may already be groaning,
for at least five minutes per week.
Okay, so five days per week, that's a lot,
but at least five minutes per week,
five minutes per week is not that much.
"Using static stretching may be beneficial
to promote range of motion improvements."
Okay, I've read this study in detail now,
they highlight, again, the
reduction in flexibility
that occurs from 20-49
years of age and so on,
how acute bouts of short-term stretching
up to three weeks can
improve stretch tolerance.
I think that's a key point
that in the short-term,
the first three weeks of embarking
on a stretching and flexibility program,
much of the improvements
come from the short-term
neural improvements that
we talked about before
of inhibiting the
spindle reflex and so on.
And also, a stretch tolerance,
a comfort with doing the movements
and maybe even a comfort in overriding
some of the pain mechanisms.
I'll talk a little bit more
about that in just a bit
and the particular utility of yoga.
Something that I don't often practice,
but that after reading this article
that I'll mention in a little bit,
I'm considering perhaps taking up
some form of yoga protocol.
Now, I've already highlighted
some of the key take aways from the study,
namely that we need to get at
least five minutes per week
of static stretching per muscle group.
And based on the previous
paper that we talked about,
we need to divide that five minutes
into sets of 30 seconds each.
And as I mentioned earlier,
it doesn't seem to be the case
that you can do all of that
in one day, unfortunately.
It does seem important that the frequency
of stretching practice
distributed throughout
the week is important.
So, let's talk protocols.
We are now talking about
doing static stretching,
so holding, so limiting momentum
and holding a stretch
for 30 seconds per set.
We're talking about trying to achieve
five minutes per week
of those static holds,
but that we can't do it all in one session
because the frequency of sessions
distributed throughout the week
correlates with the improvements
in limb range of motion.
So, what this means is that
we should probably be doing
anywhere from two to four sets
of 30 second static holds stretches
five days per week or
some variant thereof.
And I do say some variant
thereof because it turns out
that even though there
was that earlier study
that we talked about
that holding a stretch
for more than 30 seconds,
in that case 60 seconds,
didn't turn out to be
additionally beneficial.
It appears that if you
do hold those stretches
for 60 seconds per static
stretching set, for instance,
you can get away with stretching
fewer days per week overall.
So, in order to make
this as clear as possible
'cause I do realize there
are a lot of parameters
and you might be asking,
"Why didn't you just make me a list
of the exact things I should do?"
Well, it doesn't work that way
because once you understand the mechanisms
and once you understand
your particular goals,
this information is designed
for you to be able to construct
a stretching program that is tailored
to your specific goals.
If I just gave you the stretching
program that I'm doing,
or I should say that I'm soon to be doing
'cause I'm soon to be doing one
based on the research for
this particular episode.
Well, that wouldn't be beneficial for you
because, for instance, if you
have very flexible hamstrings,
but not very flexible quadriceps,
or you are somebody
who is engaged in sport
or not engaged in sport,
what you need to do is
going to vary somewhat.
So, what would effective
stretching protocol look like?
We're all trying to improve
limb range of motion
for different limbs and
different muscle groups.
But just by way of example,
and it's because the one we've been using,
let's talk about hamstrings
for the time being.
This could, of course, be
applied to other muscle groups.
Let's say you want to
improve hamstring flexibility
and limb range of motion
about and around the hamstring
and involving the hamstring,
you would want to do three sets
of static stretching for the hamstring.
Again, easy to find such
exercises on the internet.
You would do that by holding
the stretch for 30 seconds,
resting some period of time,
and doing it again,
holding for 30 seconds,
resting some period of time,
and then holding it for 30 seconds.
That would be one training
session for the hamstrings.
I have to imagine that you'd
probably want to stretch
other muscle groups as
well in that same session.
Although, at least as far as I could tell,
there was no data pointing to the fact
that you couldn't do
your hamstring stretching
one part of the day
and your quadricep stretching
another part of the day.
But presumably, you're
going to want to combine
your flexibility training
into one single session.
So, three sets of 30 seconds each
get 90 seconds,
and you would do that
ideally five times a week
or maybe even more
because it does seem like frequency
distributed throughout the
week is an important parameter.
Now, one thing that we
have not highlighted
or at least described
is how long to rest
between stretching sets.
And despite my efforts,
I could not find
research-backed information
that pointed to whether
or not 30 seconds of rest
for every 30 seconds stretching,
or 60 seconds rest for every
30 second stretching was ideal.
I think it's reasonable to assume
that doubling the amount of time
for the interleaving rest
would be appropriate or at least doable.
If anyone out there has
knowledge about rest
between stretching sets
and has some physiology,
or some biology, or some
experiential information
as to why a given ratio of
duration of static stretch
to rest in between static
stretch sets ought to be used,
please put it in the comments on YouTube,
that'd be a terrific way for
us to get that information.
I'd love to do any follow-up
to links that you provide and so on.
But now, we're starting
to build into a protocol
that is backed by the scientific data.
Three sets of 30 seconds of holds
done five times or maybe
even six times per week.
One thing that did show
up in my exploration
of the peer-reviewed research
is this notion of warming up for all this.
We haven't talked about that yet.
In general, to avoid injury,
it's a good idea to raise your
core body temperature a bit
before doing these kinds of stretches.
Even these static stretches,
which we can sort of ease into
and don't involve ballistic
movement by definition.
And the basic take away
that I was able to find
was that if we are
already warm from running,
or from weight training,
or from some other activity
that doing the static stretching
practice at the end of
that weight training,
or cardiovascular, or
other physical session
would allow us to go immediately
into the stretching session
because we're already warm, so to speak.
Otherwise, raising one's core
body temperature by a bit
by doing five to seven,
maybe even 10 minutes
of easy cardiovascular exercise
or calisthenic movements,
provided you can do those
without getting injured,
seems to be an ideal way to
warm up the body for stretching.
We should be warm or warm-up to stretch,
although those warm-ups
don't have to be extremely extensive.
And then, just by way of logic,
doing the static stretching
after resistance training
or cardiovascular training
seems to be most beneficial.
In fact, and unfortunately
we don't have time
to go into this in too much detail today,
I was able to find a number of
papers that make the argument
that static stretching prior
to cardiovascular training
and maybe even prior
to resistance training
can limit our performance
in running and resistance training.
I realize that's a controversial area,
you have those who say, "No,
it's immensely beneficial,"
it inhibits performance,"
and those that say, "No, it's a matter
of how exactly you perform
that static stretching,
and which muscle groups,
and how you're doing this,
and how much time in between
static stretching and performance."
But to leave all that aside,
doing static stretching after
some other form of exercise
and if not after some form of exercise,
after a brief warm-up to raise
your core body temperature
definitely seems like the right way to go.
Now, for some of you out there,
and I confess for me as well,
doing something five days a week
seems like a big commitment,
even if that commitment is
one to only do three sets
of 30 second static stretches.
I say this because you've got the warm-up,
I generally like to
bring a kind of a focus
and dedication to a practice.
And, of course, because when
doing these kinds of protocols,
it's likely that you're not
just stretching your hamstring,
so it's not just 90 seconds of work
with a minute of rest in between,
but very likely that we're also
doing quadricep stretching,
and also doing stretching
for the shoulders,
and stretching for the back,
and the neck, and so on.
And so, that entire session
is going to take some time,
and five days a week is a
pretty serious commitment
for most, especially for those
of us that don't exercise
or do athletics for a
living, which I don't.
So, there is some evidence
from the literature
that one can get away with,
or I don't even know that
we should think about it
as getting away with,
but that one can do longer
hold static stretches
of up to say 60 seconds,
but do fewer total sessions per week.
So, rather than three
30 second static holds,
doing three 60 second static holds
and doing those every other day.
And there really hasn't been
a systematic exploration of this.
The article that I was referring
to just a few moments ago,
this analysis of the 23 articles
was combined into this
enormous set of tables
and some really quite nice graphs
that you're welcome to look at
since we're going to
provide a link to the study.
There are a couple of key take
aways that I want to mention
that are separate from this issue
of how long to stretch and how often.
First of all, they describe
in their discussion
that there were improvements
in range of motion
independent of whether or not
people did static stretching,
active stretching, passive stretching,
ballistic stretching, or PNF stretching.
So, all of those forms of stretching
will improve limb range of motion.
This is essential to point out
and I want to emphasize this.
Static stretching, however,
gave the greatest degree of
gains in limb range of motion.
And on average, they saw a 20.9% increase,
but some of the other
increases they observed
were also quite substantial.
So, ballistic stretching can also provide
some pretty impressive limb
range of motion improvements.
However, they tended to be in the range
of, here they point out, 11.65% increase,
or in the case of PNF, a 15% increase.
So, it appears that the
greatest improvements
in limb range of motion for
your time spent and effort spent
is going to be this minimum
of five minutes per week
to elicit a significant response
with five days being the minimum
weekly recommended frequency
to achieve significant range
of motion improvements.
I confess, this was
pretty surprising to me
when I compare flexibility training
to, say, resistance training
for strength and hypertrophy.
I've had the experience,
and I know that other people
have had the experience,
and I think Dr. Andy
Galpin would probably agree
that provided one trains
hard enough and appropriately
that you don't need to
train resistance training
five days a week in order to
get significant improvements
in strength and hypertrophy.
Some people might need to,
but you can get a lot of positive results
in those variables with
less frequent training,
certainly with three or four
days a week of training.
And for cardiovascular training,
I'm not aware of anyone having tested
whether or not one very long run each week
can actually increase
cardiovascular fitness
and you're not doing anything else.
Although, I have to
imagine you'd probably see
some improvement compared
to not doing anything,
but most people are doing
repeated training sessions
of cardiovascular strength training.
Not a lot of people are
doing five days a week
of strength training, at
least that I'm aware of.
Some people are, but most
people I think are not.
And some people are
doing five or more days
a week of cardiovascular training.
I'm guessing that most people
are not doing five days a week
of dedicated static stretch
range of motion directed training,
but it does appear that that
frequency about the week
getting those repeated sessions,
even if they are short for
an individual muscle group,
turns out to be important.
And so, that points to perhaps the reason
why so few people are doing
dedicated range of motion work,
but it also reminds me
that all of the studies
that were described at
least in this review
and some of the other ones that were not
really show impressive changes
in limb range of motion.
I mean, 20+%, or even 15% with PNF,
I mean, these are big changes
that are going to benefit us,
they're going to offset
the age-related losses
in flexibility, for sure,
if one is dedicated about these practices.
And in many cases,
they're going to increase
limb range of motion
in ways that are going to
allow us better performance
in certain physical endeavors,
certainly better balance.
All right, we haven't really talked
about balance and stability,
but range of motion can
impair balance and stability
in some extreme circumstances,
but by and large, limb range
of motion, lack of tightness,
improved posture, improved
physical performance, excuse me.
And things of that sort is something
that I think we can all benefit from,
and that are key features of longevity.
We don't often think of them
because we so prioritize
cardiovascular health
and the relationship between
the heart and brain health,
and resistance training, and
musculoskeletal hypertrophy,
or strength, et cetera.
But as I delved into this literature,
it really highlighted for me the extent
to which having really
good limb range of motion,
at least maintaining limb range of motion
as we age from year to year,
and maybe even improving
limb range of motion
can be immensely beneficial
for reducing pain
for, again, improving posture,
improving our ability to
perform, to walk, et cetera.
And indeed, there's a whole literature
that relates our limb range of motion
to things like pain management
of things related to headache
and so on and so forth.
So, limb range of motion is not just about
becoming a contortionist
or being able to complete the yoga class,
it really is about maintaining
the integrity and the health
of the neuromuscular system,
the connective tissue,
and the neuromuscular connective network
because those are indeed
working as an ecosystem
and a network.
I'd like to just briefly touch
on PNF stretching for a moment.
Again, this is a vast landscape
with many parameters and
different practitioners,
a lot of competing opinions out there,
to put it lightly.
Nonetheless, I do want to
emphasize that the PNF training
leverages those spindle mechanisms
and GTO mechanisms that
we talked about earlier,
but I realize that in describing
the quadricep contraction,
hamstring stretch little mini-experiment
that hopefully you did,
that I didn't really highlight
the role of the GTOs,
the Golgi tendon organs that much.
And I just would like to just
briefly do that for a moment.
The GTOs have multiple functions.
In fact, I think even though GTOs
are in every medical textbook,
every physiology textbook,
every first year neuroscientist
learns about them
when learning about the
neuromuscular junctions
and the mechanisms of
interoception, et cetera,
they're likely to have
other functions as well.
And one of the reasons why
PNF stretching does work,
whether or not you're
doing that by using a strap
to pull back a limb,
or whether or not you're
actively contracting
your quadriceps to then
release and emphasize
stretch range of motion
for your hamstrings
and related muscle groups is
that activation of those GTOs,
meaning putting loads and
tension into that system
can inhibit the spindles
in the opposite
antagonistic muscle groups.
Okay, so one of the reasons why flexing,
or I should say
contracting your quadriceps
really intensely for some period of time
allows your hamstrings to
subsequently experience
greater range of motion.
And again, it's not just the hamstrings,
but the related connective tissue
and neural circuits, et cetera
is because yes, it's
quote-unquote relaxing
the hamstrings and the spindle,
but there's also a direct relationship
between activation of
the GTOs in the quadricep
and release of the spindles
in the hamstring and related muscles.
This has a name, it's
called autogenic inhibition,
it's a fancy name for
contraction of one muscle group
providing a relaxation
of the other muscle group
that's antagonistic to it.
And it relates back to this idea
of interleaving sets in the gym.
So, if you think back to that example,
now it should make sense
as to why, for instance,
if you do, let's say,
a set of bench presses
or shoulder presses,
and you let's say you get 10 repetitions
and you fail on the 11th,
that muscle is very, very fatigued.
If you were to rest some period of time
and then go back and do another set,
well, during the rest, that
muscle group has been relaxing,
it's obviously not
contracting the same way
it was during the resistance set,
but by going and doing a pulling exercise
that involves the
antagonistic muscle group,
so strongly contracting the
back muscles through a pull
like a pull-down, or a chin-up,
or a row-type exercise,
you're activating or near
activating the GTO system
in those pulling muscles in a way
that provides autogenic inhibition
for the pushing muscles.
Now, again, the physios out there
are probably either screaming
or banging their heads
against whatever sound system
this happens to be arriving
through to them saying, "Wait,
but in many cases, the GTOs
aren't activated enough
to provide that autogenic inhibition."
That's true, but even the
sub-threshold activation
of those intraspinal circuits,
so the place where the GTO circuit
and the spindle circuit interact,
can provide an additional replenishment
of, say, the pushing muscles
while you're activating
those pulling muscles.
And this is at least one, not the only,
but at least one mechanism
by which interleaving push
and pull, push and pull
for both strength and
hypertrophy training,
but also for range of motion
stretching-type training
can allow you to achieve better results
in a shorter period of time.
And I raise this because
I want to keep in mind
the efficiency of any training program.
We just a moment ago
established that doing,
for example, three sets
of 30 second static holds
can be very useful for the hamstrings
with let's just say for sake
of simplicity and practicality
a minute's rest in between.
But during that minute's rest,
you can stretch the opposite
antagonistic muscle group,
such as the quadriceps,
or if you want to use PNF training,
you could do loading of
the quadriceps in between.
So, there are a number of different ways
in which you can start to
interleave static stretching
with PNF stretching,
you can start to interleave
even PNF-type protocols
with resistance training,
although that gets a bit more complicated.
You can really start to construct
and build protocols
that are ideal for you.
What we will do
is for an upcoming Neural
Network Newsletter.
So, for those of you that aren't familiar,
the Huberman Lab Podcast
has a so-called Neural Network Newsletter,
these are monthly newsletters
where we put distilled points
from the podcast and oftentimes protocols
in a downloadable PDF form.
You can access it by giving us your email,
we don't share your email with anybody.
If you want to see examples of these,
you can go to hubermanlab.com
and go to the menu and see Newsletter,
you don't have to sign up for anything
to see examples of what these are like.
I'll provide a couple
of different protocols,
one that is pure static stretching,
one that involves PNF-type stretching,
and I'll also put down a protocol
that involves the antagonistic
interleaved muscle training
of the sort that I've been describing
a few times throughout this episode.
And then, you can try and apply those
either separately or maybe
combine them in some way
that's useful for your goals.
There are a couple of key
elements that are essential
for building a safe and
effective range of motion
increasing program that arrived to us
both through the peer-reviewed research
and, admittedly, from people
that have been involved
in teaching and training range of motion
for a very long period of time.
Some of you may be familiar
with the so-called Anderson method,
it's been around for a long time.
Actually have never met Anderson,
I don't, I should know this,
I don't even know if he's still alive,
I hope he's still alive,
but in any event, there are
a lot of different features
to the Anderson and other protocols.
But one of the aspects
of the Anderson protocol
that I think is highly relevant.
In fact, I know is relevant
to the peer-reviewed research
that we're going to talk
about in a few moments
is this notion of pushing through pain,
and how active or how passive
to be about static stretching.
Now, this is somewhat subjective.
Right, if you think about
getting into a stretch,
again, we'll just use the
hamstrings for example.
So, you're either reaching
for your toes while seated,
or maybe you're using a strap
and you're raising your foot
overhead while lying down,
or maybe you're doing a
toe touch-type exercise.
How far should you reach?
Where is the end range of motion?
Should you balance?
Should you not balance?
We're going to talk a little
bit more about that in a moment,
but Anderson has an
interesting idea and principle,
which has thread through
a lot of his teachings
that I think are very much
in keeping with the study
that I'm about to describe next,
where he emphasizes to yes,
to stretch to the end
of the range of motion,
but not to focus so much on
where that range of motion
happens to be that day.
So, for instance, not thinking, "Oh,
I can always touch my toes, for instance.
And therefore that's the starting place
for my flexibility training today."
But rather to take the entirety
of your system into account
each day and understand that, okay,
provided your warmed up appropriately,
that you're now going to
stretch your hamstrings,
for instance, and you're going
to reach down for your toes,
but that your range of motion
might be adjusted that day
by way of tension and stress,
or by way of ambient
temperature in the room.
And to basically define
the end range of motion
as the place where you
can feel the stretch
in the relevant muscle groups.
I think this is important
because unlike resistance training
or cardiovascular training,
where we can measure
distance traveled over time
in the case of cardiovascular training,
or how much weight is on the bar,
and count repetitions, et cetera.
With range of motion training,
of course, range of motion is the feature
that we're interested in,
but there is likely to be a lot
of variation from day-to-day
based on a number of different internal
and external factors.
And so, the Anderson method
is really about getting into static
and other forms of stretching.
I think today we've mainly been focusing
on static stretching and
holding the end range of motion,
but really paying attention
to the feel of the stretch
and the muscles involved.
And there are parallels in resistance
and cardiovascular training
too I realize, right?
In the case of trying
to build hypertrophy,
or I should say improve
hypertrophy, muscle size,
oftentimes the best
advice that one can give
is to don't try to lift weights,
but rather to challenge muscles.
Now, of course, you need
to provide adequate loads
in order to get hypertrophy,
but when you're training
purely for strength,
it's about moving weights.
When you're training
purely for hypertrophy
or mainly for hypertrophy,
it's really about challenging
muscles using weights
or other forms of resistance.
And similarly, and in keeping
with this Anderson method,
when trying to build limb range of motion,
doing static stretching at a
place where it's difficult,
but that you can experience
the stretch of the muscle
cognitively, consciously being
able to focus on the muscles
and their stretch is at least as useful
as is evaluating the
current range of motion
you're able to achieve.
So, what does this mean?
This means feel the muscles
as you stretch them,
don't just go through the motions.
And this means don't get so attached
to being able to always achieve,
for instance, a stretch
of a given distance
within a given session.
You might actually find that
by just finding the place
where you can't get much further
and holding the static stretch there,
that on the second and third set
that you happen to be doing that day,
that your range of motion will
be increased considerably.
Maybe not, but very likely yes, you will.
And, of course, evaluating
range of motion over time
is the key parameter
because that's the goal
of all this type of work.
Now, along these lines,
there is this variable that
we've mentioned a few times
of passive versus active stretching,
and there's this even
more nebulous variable,
this even more kind of subjective thing
of how much effort to put into it?
Should you push into the stretch?
Would you even want to balance a tiny bit?
Would you want to reach
into that end point
and try and extend it within
a given set and session?
And for that reason,
I was excited to find this paper
entitled A Comparison of
Two Stretching Modalities
on Lower-Limb Range of Motion Measurements
in Recreational Dancers.
Happens to be done in
recreational dancers,
it's a six-week intervention program
that compared low-intensity stretching,
which they call Microstretching.
They used a capital M,
so I don't know if that
means that it's proprietary,
although I didn't see evidence
of a conflict of interest,
but they call it Microstretching.
But to be very clear,
Microstretching in the
case of this manuscript
is low-intensity stretching.
And they compared that
with moderate intensity static stretching
on an active and passive ranges of motion.
Okay, so there are a lot of
different variables are here,
but I'll just highlight
a few of the things
that are really most relevant to us,
and I'll give you the
take away at the outset
and then return to it at the end
so that if I lose any of your attention
in the next couple of minutes,
at least you have that key take away.
Basically, what they found
was that a six-week training program
using very low-intensity stretching
had a greater positive effect
on lower limb range of motion
than did moderate-intensity
static stretching.
I find that incredibly
interesting, so very low intensity,
and we'll define what
that means in a moment.
Here, I'm quoting them,
"The most interesting aspect of the study
was the greater increase
in active range of motion
compared to passive range of motion
by the Microstretching group."
So, this relates to what
we were just talking about
a few moments ago as it
relates to the Anderson method,
which is that very
low-intensity stretching,
meaning effort that feels not painful
and in fact might even feel
easy or at least not straining
to exceed a given range of motion
turns out to not just be as effective,
but more effective than
moderate-intensity stretching.
So, what is low-intensity
static stretching?
Well, they define this as
the stretches were completed
at an intensity of 30-40%
where 100% equals the
point of pain, right?
So, 30-40% in these individuals,
and again, I'm paraphrasing,
induced a relaxed state
within the individual
and the specific muscle.
And here they were holding
these static stretches
I should mention for one
minute, not 30 seconds.
Now, the control group
was doing the exact same overall protocol,
so daily stretching for six weeks,
the same exercises, holding
each set for 60 seconds,
but were using an
intensity of stretch of 80%
where, again, 100
represents the point of pain
or the point where the person
would want to stop stretching.
I find these data incredibly interesting
for, I think, what ought
to be obvious reasons.
If you're going to embark on a flexibility
and stretching training program,
you don't need to push
to the point of pain.
In fact, it seems that
even just approaching
the point of pain is
going to be less effective
than operating at this 30-40% of intensity
prior to reaching that pain threshold.
The pain threshold being 100%.
Now, of course, this is pretty subjective,
but I think all of us should be able
to register within ourselves,
so whether a given range of motion
or extending a given range of motion
brings us to that threshold
of pain or near pain.
And according to this study at least,
operating or performing stretching
at an intensity that's quite
low, that's very relaxing
turns out to be more beneficial
in increasing range of motion
than is doing exercises aimed
at increasing range of motion
at a higher intensity.
Okay, so lower intensity stretching,
I should say lower
intensity static stretching
appears to be the most beneficial way
to approach stretching.
And I think that's a relief
probably to many of us
because it also suggests
that the injury risk
is going to be lower
than if one were pushing
into the pain zone, so to speak.
The authors offer a number
of different explanations
as to why this approach, this
Microstretching approach,
might be more effective.
Here, I'm paraphrasing
from their discussion
where they mentioned that
it could be hypothesized
that they had improved
reciprocal inhibition
within the hamstring muscle group.
So, this gets right back to
the sorts of neural mechanisms
that we talked about before,
that somehow by doing this
low-intensity stretching
that they were able to
access some of those spindle
and GTO-type mechanisms that
we were referring to earlier,
and the inhibition of hamstring
and quadricep stretches.
They also offer a number
of different ideas
about how this could shift the activation
of the so-called sympathetic,
remember the kind of stress
division of our nervous system,
and to reduce that relative
to activation of the parasympathetic arm
of the nervous system.
I confess, they have a couple of arguments
around sympathetic, parasympathetic
that are somewhat convoluted.
I will just in fairness
to the neuroscience
on those systems,
I wouldn't suggest putting too much weight
on their arguments about
sympathetic and parasympathetic.
To my mind, they didn't
really hold much water,
but here I'm not trying to be disparaging
of the overall work, which I
think is really quite sound,
which is that low intensity,
so called Microstretching,
is going to be the most effective way
to increase limb range
of movement over time.
I want to just briefly return to this idea
of whether or not to do
ballistic or static stretching
before some sort of skill training,
or weight training, or any kind of sport,
or even cardiovascular
exercise like running.
Again, the data are
really split out there.
There are even folks who suggest
that doing any kind of
stretching prior to running
is going to lower running efficiency,
it's going to require
essentially more work
and more oxygen uptake at a given speed
for a variety of reasons,
and runners and that community
argue about this endlessly.
There are papers in both
sides, in both directions,
I'm sure I'll hear about
some of this in the comments.
I'm not really going to take a
stance on this as a consequence
because the data are all over the place.
However, I think there's a
general logic that we can apply,
and here I'm borrowing
from some conversations
and some information put out
there by Dr. Andy Galpin,
who I think is, of course, both an expert
and thinks about these things
in a really sound and
flexible way, no pun intended.
There are instances, for example,
where an individual might want
to do some static stretching
to increase limb range of motion
prior to doing weight training
even if it's going to
inhibit that person's ability
to lift as much weight.
Why would you want to do that?
Well, for instance,
if somebody has a
tightness or a limitation
in their neuromuscular
connective tissue system
someplace in their body and system
that prevents them from using proper form,
that they can overcome by
doing some static stretching.
Well, that would be a great idea
as Dr. Galpin points out.
Or for instance, if proper
stability within the movement
requires increasing limb
range of motion in some way,
well then compromising
the use of greater loads
could be greatly offset by
doing some static stretching
to improve, say, hamstring flexibility
or another muscle group flexibility.
So, we can't always think about
just what's going to allow us
or inhibit us from using
the maximal amount of weight
or from running as far as we want to run
as fast as we want to run.
There are instances where
people are trying to overcome
injuries where they're trying to come back
from a repetitive surgery
or something of that sort,
coming back from a layoff
where some additional static stretching
prior to cardiovascular,
or weight training,
or skill training, or sport of some kind
is going to be useful
because it's going to put us
in a position of greater safety
and confidence and performance overall,
even if it's adjusting down our speed
or the total amount of loads that we use.
So, it's you that needs to consider
whether or not for you and
within a given training session
you want to do static training,
I should say static stretching
range of motion training
prior to or after that training session.
And similarly, there are a lot of data
pointing to the fact
that doing some dynamic
or even ballistic stretching
prior to skill training,
or cardiovascular, or weight
training can be beneficial
in part to warm-up the
relevant neural circuits,
joints, and connective
tissue, and muscles,
and as well to perhaps
improve range of motion
or ability to perform those
movements more accurately,
with more stability, and
therefore with more confidence.
And while Dr. Andy Galpin
would never name any
protocol after himself,
he's far too humble to do that,
I've named a couple of
protocols after him,
particularly the Galpin
equation for hydration,
because he was willing to
stick his neck out there
and put down some specific
numbers that people could follow
in order to ensure proper
hydration during training,
you can look up the
Galpin equation elsewhere.
You can just Google it or
look elsewhere and find it.
And Dr. Galpin has also been
very thoughtful and generous,
and I think very accurate in offering
a kind of a general organizational logic
for how to think about the goals
of a particular training session,
and thereby to decide whether or not
you're going to do ballistic,
or static stretching,
and so on and so forth.
So, we can refer to this
general approach as Galpinian.
Galpinian, is that right?
Galpin-ian logic, Galpinian logic.
Thus far, we've been
talking about stretching
for sake of increasing limb
flexibility and range of motion,
but there are other reasons perhaps
to embark on a stretching protocol
that include both our ability to relax
and access deep relaxation quickly,
as well as even to reduce inflammation
and perhaps even combat
certain forms of cancer.
And if that sounds really far-fetched,
I want to emphasize that the study
I'm about to share with you in a moment
was actually carried out
by one of the directors
of a division of the National
Institutes of Health.
And this was the work of Helene Langevin,
who's a medical doctor, has
done really important work
on the mechanisms underlying
things like acupuncture
and has approached all that
from a very mechanistic viewpoint.
Right, so not looking just at
the effects of acupuncture,
but really trying to understand
what sorts of cytokines,
inflammatory molecules,
and pathways are activated?
What sorts of neural
mechanisms get engaged
by things like acupuncture
that impinges on the fascial
tissues and so forth?
And Dr. Langevin is currently
Director of the National Institutes
of Complementary Health and Medicine
at the National Institutes of Health.
So, this is a major division
supported by tax dollars
that support systematic
mechanistic exploration
of things like respiration,
meditation, yoga, acupuncture.
So, this is serious science
applied to protocols
and approaches that have been
used for some period of time,
but really aimed at trying to understand
what would the best protocols
be to evolve new protocols?
So, there's a really interesting study
done in animal models,
but I think it's a powerful enough result
that I think we all should
pay attention to it.
The title of this paper,
and, again, the last author
is Dr. Langevin herself,
is Stretching Reduces Tumor Growth
in a Mouse Breast Cancer Model.
And yes, you can get mice to stretch,
it turns out that if you gently
lift up mice by their tail
and they'll hold onto their cage,
there's a way in which you
can mechanically stretch them
in a way that doesn't harm them.
First, I should mention
that Dr. Langevin and others
have shown that just a brief
whole body stretch of that sort
induces an increase in activation
of the parasympathetic arm
of the autonomic nervous system,
again, not arm, limb arm,
but the aspect of the
autonomic nervous system
that creates a whole body,
whole nervous system shift
toward more relaxation.
So, yes, indeed stretching
induces relaxation at a systemic level,
not just at a local level.
And I think that's important,
probably not surprising to those of you
that use stretching regularly,
but yes, it does indeed relax us.
Yes, you can do this in mice
and see that in mice as well.
Here's what they did
for this current study,
or I should say this was
a study published in 2018
in Scientific Reports.
They write, "Recent studies have shown
that gentle daily stretching
for 10 minutes can reduce
local connective tissue
inflammation and fibrosis."
Now, that's local tissue
inflammation and fibrosis
as well we now know as
systemic inflammation
and can induce relaxation systemically.
In this case, they focused
on mice, not humans.
And mice were randomized to a stretch
versus no stretch condition
and were treated for 10 minutes
once a day for four weeks.
So, it's 10 minutes of this
passive whole body stretching
a day for four weeks.
What's remarkable, I mean,
just I have to say is just striking
is that tumor volume in these mice,
they were able to induce
tumors in these mice
and the tumor volume at the
end point was 52% smaller
in the stretch group compared
to the no stretch group.
This is a highly significant effect,
and they point out in the
absence of any other treatment.
And they explored whether or
not cytotoxic immune responses
were activated and a
number of other features.
They weren't able to get too deeply
into the underlying mechanisms,
but this is pretty remarkable.
Even three weeks into stretching protocol,
this daily stretching
protocol for these mice
tumor volume was reduced, I
mean, by it's almost halved,
this is pretty incredible.
So, they have these
measures of tumor volume
and the only difference
in the way these animals
were treated and handled
was the introduction
of this daily stretch.
I find this result to
be, of course, limited
in to the extent that it's
done in an animal model,
not in humans, we have to point it out,
but as they point out in their discussion,
"Our results demonstrate a 52% reduction
in mammary tumor growth over one month
in mice undergoing stretching
for 10 minutes a day
without any other form of therapy."
Do they think that stretching itself
is changing the tumor size?
No, in fact they raise the
possibility that stretching
because of its impact on the fascia
might even create micro environments
that are more permissive for tumor growth
in certain instances,
so they're careful to emphasize
what I also believe to be the case,
which is that it's unlikely
that the stretching itself
was directly acting to reduce tumor size,
but rather that there's this possible link
between inflammation and
immune exhaustion mechanisms
that if you can periodically
relax a nervous system,
here through stretching,
that it can affect certain pathways
related to the immune system
that would allow the immune
system to combat tumor growth
to a significant degree.
So, again, even though
this is a study in mice,
it argues that relaxation
induced by stretching
can have a powerful influence
on mammary tumor growth.
Again, a huge effect carried out
by one of the premier labs and individuals
who do this sort of work and
think about this sort of thing.
And, of course, I want to point out
it wasn't just Dr. Langevin
that did this study,
there are a number of
co-authors on the study
we will provide a link to the co-authors,
excuse me, we will provide
a link to the study
so that you can peruse it
in more detail if you like.
Now, as a related and
somewhat final point,
I'd like to return to
this idea and this place,
this real estate within our brain
that we call the insular
cortex, the insula.
As you recall, way back at
the beginning of this episode,
we were talking about
the von Economo neurons,
that Constantin von Economo
the Austrian scientist discovered.
And the fact that we are able to make
and perform interpretations of
our internal landscape pain,
our dedication to a practice,
for instance, whether
or not we are in pain
because it's a practice that
we are doing intentionally
and want to improve ourselves,
or whether or not it's
pain that's arriving
through some externally
imposed demands or situations.
Well, the insula is handling all that.
And fortunately, there's a wonderful paper
that was published,
it was a few years ago now in
the journal Cerebral Cortex,
which is a fine journal.
This is the year 2014
entitled Insular Cortex Mediates
Increased Pain Tolerance
in Yoga Practitioners.
I'll tell you why I like this study.
I'm personally not a practitioner of yoga,
I've taken a few yoga
classes over the years,
I've done some of the hot yoga classes.
Those rooms can get really,
really warm, I confess,
and I've done the kind of
standard yoga every now and again.
It's not something that
I've kept up regularly.
This study explored the effects
on brain structure volume
in yoga practitioners.
And for those of you out there
that are aficionados in yoga,
they pulled subjects from
having backgrounds in the...
Here, I'm probably going to mispronounce
these different things, and forgive me,
the Vinysasa yogas, the Ashtanga yogas,
the Iyengar yogas, the Sivananda yogas.
Okay, so some people were
new to these practices,
some were experienced.
That the important take aways
were that they took
these yoga practitioners
and they didn't explore
their brain structure
in the context of yoga itself,
they looked at things like pain tolerance.
So, they used thermal stimulation,
basically they put people into conditions
where they gave them very
hot or very cold stimuli
and compared those yoga practitioners
of varying levels of yoga experience
to those that had no experience with yoga,
so-called controls.
And they found some
really interesting things,
there are a lot of data in this paper,
but here's something
I'd like to highlight.
The pain tolerance of yoga practitioners
was double or more to that
of non-yoga practitioners,
even for those that weren't
doing this so-called hot yoga.
Right, they also found that pain tolerance
was significantly greater,
both for heat pain and for cold pain.
They also found significant
increases in insula,
again, the insula, this brain region,
gray matter volume.
Typically, when we talk about gray matter,
we're talking about the
so-called cell bodies,
the location in neurons
where the genome is housed
and where the kind of all the
housekeeping stuff is there.
And then white matter volume
tends to be the axons,
the wires because they're
ensheathed with this stuff
that appears white in MRIs,
and indeed is white under the microscope,
and indeed is white, it's
actually lipid, which is myelin.
So, increased gray matter
volume of the insula
is a significant finding
because what it suggests is
that people that are doing yoga
have an increased volume
of these areas of the brain
that are associated with
interoceptive awareness
and for being able to
make judgements about pain
and why one is experiencing pain,
not just to lean away from pain,
but to utilize or leverage
or even overcome pain.
So, there are many studies of
yoga and meditation out there,
few that have as much
mechanistic detail as this one.
And in fact, there's a beautiful figure,
Figure 3 in this paper
that shows that the gray matter volume
of this particular brain region
scales in a almost linear way
with the duration of yoga practice
that somebody has been taking on in years.
So, people that had, well,
hey had a few subjects
that have up to 15 or 16
years of yoga practice
had much larger left
insula gray matter volume,
bigger brain areas associated
with these abilities.
And I find this interesting
because there are a lot
of activities out there
that don't create these kind
of changes in brain volume,
especially within the insula.
So, it appears that it's
not just the performance
of the yogic movements,
but the overcoming or the kind of pushing
into the end ranges of motion
and to push through
discomfort to some extent,
of course, we want people doing
that in a healthy, safe way,
but that allows yoga practitioners
to build up the structure and function
of these brain areas that
allow them to cope with pain
better than other individuals,
and to cope with other kinds
of interoceptive challenges,
if you will, not just pain but cold,
not just pain but discomfort
of being in a particular
position to do that.
And again, we wouldn't want
people placing themselves
into a compromised position
literally that would harm them,
especially given that earlier we heard
that Microstretching of
the kind of non-painful
sort low-intensity sort is
actually going to be more effective
for increasing end range of motion.
But this study really
emphasizes the extent to which
practitioners of yoga
don't just learn movements,
they learn how to control
their nervous system in ways
that really reshapes their
relationship to pain,
to flexibility, and to the kinds of things
that the neuromuscular
system was designed to do.
And as a final point,
there's a beautiful graph in this paper,
beautiful I think because it explores
some of the more subjective
dimensions of yoga
and insula function,
which is a here I'll read
it out in the nerdy form
and then I'll explain what it means,
"This is a frequency histogram
of categories of mental
strategies used by yogis
versus controls during the
cold pain tolerance task."
What they're describing here and showing
is quantitatively how
people are conceptualizing
cold pain in order to get through it.
And the different categories
are, for instance,
distraction, right?
Some people just choose to
distract themselves from pain
or to attempt to, other
people will try to ignore it,
it's a lot like distraction,
but nonetheless, to engage
in a negative emotion,
sort of like, "[growls]
like I'm going to dig,
I'm going to be in resistance to this."
Control subjects tended
to use those approaches,
whereas practitioners
of yoga tended to use
other sorts of subjective
approaches like positive imagery
to some extent,
the ability to relax
despite the extreme cold,
the ability to quote-unquote accept
like, "This is just happening,"
despite the extreme cold,
to observe, to third person themselves.
And the greatest effect,
of course, was to breathe,
to focus on their respiration
as a way to deal with this
challenge, this cold challenge.
Now, all of that are subjective data,
but I want to remind you that
the practitioners of yoga
are not just using entirely
different mental strategies,
but they are far more
effective at dealing with pain,
their pain tolerance is much higher
as evidenced by the other data
in the previous graphs in the paper.
So, while this podcast episode
is most certainly not about yoga per se,
it's about flexibility and stretching,
flexibility and stretching are elements
within yogic practices.
And, of course, yogic practices
involve breathing and mental work,
and a lot of other things
balance, et cetera.
It's a vast landscape
as as many of you know.
But I think that if ever
there was a manuscript
that pointed to the utility
of something like yoga
for sake of tapping into a
particular set of brain circuits
and mechanisms that could wick out
into multiple dimensions of life,
so day-to-day life, stress,
challenges in dealing with all
sorts of external stressors,
career-related,
family-related, relationally,
et cetera, et cetera, excuse me,
but as well for increasing range of motion
for increasing flexibility.
So, if ever there was a practice
that one could embark on
that would not only increase flexibility
and limb range of motion,
but would also allow one to cultivate
some improved mental functioning
as it relates to pain tolerance
and other features of stress management
that no doubt wick out
into other areas of life,
appears that yoga is a
quite useful practice.
And so, for those of
you that are interested
in increasing limb range of motion
and you're already a
practitioner of yoga, great.
I can imagine that someday
there'll be another study
like this one and you'll be in that 10
or 15-16 year practitioner graph.
You'll be that dot way out
on the far end of the graph
that shows that your
insula is that much bigger
than the rest of ours,
and therefore your internal
awareness, and pain thresholds,
and stress management
will be that much better,
but of course, yoga isn't the only way
to increase limb range of
motion and flexibility.
Up until now, we've described
a number of different ways to do that
and we've arrived at some
general themes and protocols.
Again, those themes and
protocols will be distilled
into some specific and precise list
in our Neural Network Newsletter,
but we can revisit a couple of them now
just in summary and synthesis.
Static stretching appears
to be at least among
the more useful forms of stretching.
So, low or zero momentum stretching
typically at end range of motion.
I love this concept of Microstretching,
even though it's just a couple of studies
that have addressed whether
or not high-intensity
or low-intensity static stretch
holds are more beneficial.
The idea and indeed the
data that low-intensity,
so 30-40% of what would
one would consider painful
appears to be more effective
than 80% of that threshold.
I find that incredibly interesting.
And then, there's this idea of frequency,
it really does appear that getting
at least five minutes per
week total of stretching
for a given muscle group
is important for creating
meaningful, lasting changes
in limb range of motion.
And that is best achieved
by five day a week,
or six day a week, or even
seven day a week protocols,
but those can be very short protocols
limited to, say, three sets of 30,
maybe in 45 or 60 seconds of static hold.
Although, 30 seconds seems
to be a key threshold there
that can get you maximum benefit.
There is no need to do
full 60-second holds
unless you're doing fewer
total sessions per week.
And, of course, to always warm-up
or to arrive at the
stretching session warm.
And then, of course, there are
the other forms of stretching
that we touched upon a
bit, things like PNF.
And we talked about why PNF works,
things like the spindle and
the Golgi tendon organ reflexes
that are built into all of us
that we arrive in this world with.
And of course, the other
forms of stretching
that are known to be
effective and important,
such as dynamic and ballistic stretching.
Again, stretching protocols that involve
a lot of momentum in order
to improve range of motion
for performance of
particular types of work
that one is about to embark on.
Typically, that would be physical work,
but a whole interesting
and unexplored landscape
is the extent to which
changing limb range of motion
and different types of body movement
actually shape our cognitive abilities,
and that will be the
topic of a future episode
of this podcast.
If you're learning from
and/or enjoying this podcast,
please subscribe to our YouTube channel.
That's a terrific zero-cost
way to support us.
In addition, please
subscribe to our podcast
on Spotify and Apple.
And at both Spotify and Apple,
you can leave us up to a five star review.
If you have feedback such as comments
about the content of
this or other episodes,
or you have suggestions about topics
that you'd like us to explore
on the Huberman Lab Podcast
or guests that you would
like me to interview,
please put those in the
comment section on YouTube.
That's the best place for us to find them,
we do read them all,
and we do take them into consideration
when building out future programming.
Please also check out the sponsors
mentioned at the beginning
of today's episode,
that's the best way to
support this podcast.
Not so much on today's episode,
but in many episodes of
the Huberman Lab Podcast
we talk about supplements.
While supplements aren't
necessary for everybody,
many people deriv
tremendous benefit from them
for things like improving
the transition time
and depth of sleep,
or for improving focus, or
for a variety of other things
including things like anxiety management.
For that reason, the Huberman Lab Podcast
has decided to partner
with Momentous Supplements.
First of all, Momentous Supplements
are of the very highest quality,
they're used at various
professional sports teams
and they have contracts
with various government organizations
exploring the role of
particular supplements
in human performance.
Second of all, they ship internationally
because we know a number of you
are outside the country
of the United States,
we hope that will be useful to you.
As well, we wanted to
have a single location
where people could go to access
the most often discussed supplements
here on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
So, while the full catalog
of those supplements
isn't quite available yet,
many of them are available,
you can find them by going to
livemomentous.com/huberman.
Again, that's livemomentous.com/huberman
to find supplements for sleep,
for recovery from exercise,
for focus, and many other features
that impact mental health,
physical health, and performance.
If you're not already
following Huberman Lab
on Instagram and Twitter, please do so.
At both places, I describe
science and science-related tools
that relate to some of the themes
covered here on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
But oftentimes I'll do posts
that include information
and tools not detailed here
on the Huberman Lab Podcast.
We also have a newsletter,
I've mentioned this a few
times during today's episode,
it is the Neural Network Newsletter.
You can access that newsletter
completely zero of cost
by going to hubermanlab.com,
go to the menu and sign
up for our newsletter.
You supply your email,
we do not share your
email with anybody else,
we have a very clear privacy
policy that you can find there.
If you want to see examples
of previous newsletters,
you can find them there
without having to sign up.
Again, that Neural Network Newsletter
comes out about once a month
and we use it to distill
out essential protocols
from the podcast,
to synthesize information
from the podcast.
We do believe many
people find them useful,
so sign up for the
Neural Network Newsletter
if you're interested.
So, thank you once again
for joining me today
for a discussion about the neural,
and neuromuscular, and connective tissue,
and skeletal aspects of
flexibility and stretching.
And as always, thank you for
your interest in science.
[upbeat music]